programming throwdown episode 180 reinforcement learning. Take it away, Patrick. Welcome to another episode. This is going to be a good one. Excited to be here actually, because this is a topic I have been meaning to learn about and Jason has agreed to be put on his professor hat, robe. I don't know what it is a professor wear. I got hooded when I got the PhD. I got hooded, which I thought would be an actual hood, but it's really just a sash. Wait, what is getting hooded?
Programming Throwdown 第 180 期：强化学习。开始吧，Patrick。欢迎收听新一期节目。这一期会很精彩。其实我很高兴能来到这里，因为这是一个我一直想学习的主题，Jason 也同意戴上他的教授帽，或者长袍。我不知道教授穿什么。我拿博士学位时参加了授袍仪式。我被授袍了，我原以为会是一个真正的兜帽，但其实只是一条饰带。等等，什么是授袍？
That's like what you get when you get, I don't know about this. Okay. So when you get a PhD, you get hooded, which means you go through the same ceremony as the master's students, or I think the same ceremony is everybody, but you get a hood, which is actually a sash and your PhD advisor actually puts the sash around you over you as part of the ceremony. Okay. I feel like maybe I've heard that term, but I always just kind of had some weird
那就像是你得到的东西，我不太清楚这个。好吧。当你获得博士学位时，你会参加授袍仪式，这意味着你和硕士生参加同样的仪式，或者我想每个人都是同样的仪式，但你会得到一个兜帽，实际上是一条饰带，你的博士导师会在仪式上把这条饰带围在你身上。好吧。我觉得我可能听过这个词，但我总是对它有一些奇怪的……
probably bad association with hood winked. But, uh, anyways, okay. Where are we off topic? Anyways, it's fine because I actually, I actually, the first thing off topic. Anyway, so just- That's fine because I actually, the first thing I think of is actually, because I grew up in the inner cities. I was like, okay, we're going back to my childhood here. Oh, okay, interesting.
可能是不好的联想，比如“hoodwinked”（欺骗）。但，呃，总之，好吧。我们跑题了吗？总之，没关系，因为我其实……第一件跑题的事。总之，就是——没关系，因为我首先想到的是，因为我是在内城区长大的。我就想，好吧，我们要回到我的童年了。哦，好吧，有意思。
Okay, wow. All right. So today we've learned there's many associations of the word hood. So okay, we didn't even talk about cars yet. So, you get a new upgraded carbon fiber hood for your car. You get hooded. Okay, we have to have people like, what is going on? What are we listening to? Oh God.
好吧，哇。好的。所以今天我们了解到“hood”这个词有很多联想。所以好吧，我们还没谈到汽车呢。所以，你为你的车买了一个新的升级版碳纤维引擎盖（hood）。你被“授袍”（hooded）了。好吧，我们得让听众觉得，这是怎么回事？我们在听什么？天哪。
Well, that's how you know we're not the AI. They would not be this off topic. That's true. They would definitely stick to the script. The AI is not allowed to say this stuff. You would definitely be pushing the script. They are not allowed to say this stuff. You would definitely be pushing the down vote button, you know, oh wait, people probably are now. That's why it's not live.
嗯，这就是你怎么知道我们不是人工智能的原因。它们不会这么跑题。确实。它们肯定会照本宣科。人工智能不允许说这些东西。你肯定会一直按那个踩票按钮，你知道，哦等等，人们现在可能就在按。这就是为什么这不是直播。
Okay. So for, and I'll keep it brief because actually I want to get to the meat of the story today. Oh, no pun intended, but talking about cooking outside, I had a grill on my like back patio which I would use to cook cook food occasionally. It was uses these little pellets of wood so it's called like a pellet grill so like pellets feed down and it burns it and makes the heat and has an electronic controller and I would do some like you know smoking on it and some some grilling anyways it, it broke and it's old so, you know, okay, fine. So I went to go like, okay, I can get a new grill. I did not know. There are so many different
好吧。所以，我会长话短说，因为我其实想进入今天故事的核心。哦，没有双关的意思，但说到户外烹饪，我的后院露台上有一个烤架，我偶尔会用它来做饭。它用的是那种小木颗粒，所以叫颗粒烤架，颗粒喂进去，燃烧产生热量，还有一个电子控制器，我会用它来熏制和烧烤。总之，它坏了，而且很旧了，所以，你知道，好吧，没关系。所以我去想，好吧，我可以买个新烤架。我不知道。有这么多不同的……
kinds of grills that are, you know, like popular now. And I feel like growing up, my parents always just had a, yours are kind of one of two things. You were the charcoal Weber grill, you know, with the like the bowl and the charcoals or you had the propane grill grill, you know, with the like the bowl and the charcoals, or you had the propane grill that, you know, like you had the tank and you hooked up the hose and that was the two. But now there are like, you know, all sorts of things where it's, you know, infrared cookers where the propane goes into like a, some sort of like catalyst something and like turns out like the patio heaters that, you know, are at restaurants sometimes.
现在流行的烤架种类。我觉得我小时候，我父母总是只有一种，或者说只有两种。要么是 Weber 炭烤架，你知道，带那个碗和木炭的，要么是丙烷烤架，你知道，带那个罐子，接上软管，就这两种。但现在有各种各样的东西，比如红外线烹饪器，丙烷进入某种催化剂之类的东西，就像餐厅里有时用的那种露台加热器。
Yeah. It's like, I don't know. And then there's these like egg shaped, I guess they call them Komodo girls, like big green egg and Komodo. And they're like big ceramic things. And then you can get like various kinds of cabinet smoke. Like anyways, I, I just, maybe I'm naive in my, I just bought something straightforward and simple. And then I like, oh, I'm overwhelmed by the tyranny of choice. That's just all I was going to say.
是的。就像，我不知道。还有那些蛋形的，我想他们叫它们“Komodo”烤架，比如 Big Green Egg 和 Komodo。它们是那种大的陶瓷制品。然后你可以买各种各样的柜式烟熏炉。总之，我，我只是，也许我很天真，我只是买了一些简单直接的东西。然后我就，哦，我被选择的暴政淹没了。我只想说这个。
If you've never kind of looked up grill technology, it's actually kind of crazy. There's got a lot of choices here. So now I don't know what to pick. That's wild. I have a propane grill and then I have a smoker. I have a separate electric smoker that takes the pellets and smokes meat. Um, but yeah, I think the green egg can do both. So it's like a two in one.
如果你从来没有研究过烤架技术，这其实挺疯狂的。这里有很多选择。所以现在我不知道该选什么。太疯狂了。我有一个丙烷烤架，还有一个烟熏炉。我有一个单独的电动烟熏炉，用颗粒来熏肉。嗯，但我觉得 Green Egg 两者都能做。所以它是一个二合一的产品。
Um, and yeah, it's just wild. And then there's like pizza ovens now people are doing. So like when I went to go look at the grills at the hardware store, it was like, there are also pizza ovens here and yeah, I, okay. Yeah. My neighbor has a pizza oven and I think he's used it twice in four years. Well, I mean, you know, how many times do you eat pizza? I mean, and also it's like, if you eat pizza, you're often in a hurry, so you're either ordering it to go
嗯，是的，这太疯狂了。现在人们还在做披萨烤炉。所以当我去五金店看烤架时，就像是，这里还有披萨烤炉，是的，我，好吧。是的，我的邻居有一个披萨烤炉，我想他在四年里只用了两次。好吧，我是说，你知道，你吃多少次披萨？我是说，而且就像，如果你吃披萨，你通常很赶时间，所以你要么点外卖……
or you're doing the regular oven because you're in a hurry. Okay, all right, so you're down on the pizza oven. That's a short on the pizza oven stocks for Jason. Yeah, I mean, I'm not a big fan of the pizza oven. I think, I've only ever endorsed one stock on my entire programming through down career and that was Data Dog. And I think it's like up just as much as everything else.
要么用普通烤箱，因为你很赶时间。好吧，好吧，所以你不看好披萨烤炉。那是 Jason 对披萨烤炉股票的看空。是的，我是说，我不是披萨烤炉的忠实粉丝。我想，我在整个 Programming Throwdown 生涯中只推荐过一只股票，那就是 Data Dog。我觉得它和其他股票涨得一样多。
I made one like in hindsight, in five years of hindsight, like relatively neutral endorsement. Everyone's bracing themselves for the meme coin announcement now. Oh, we need a programming throw down coin. No, we don't. I'm not. No, I'm not. Right. Pulling people. Okay. I know. Okay. We got to keep going. We got to keep. We are not. We are not. Rug pulling people.
我做过一次，事后看来，在五年后的回顾中，是一个相对中立的推荐。现在每个人都在为模因币的公告做准备。哦，我们需要一个 Programming Throwdown 币。不，我们不需要。我不是。不，我不是。对。拉人头。好吧。我知道。好吧。我们得继续。我们得继续。我们不是。我们不是在拉人头。
We went the opposite way. We stopped doing ads. So it's like the opposite of rug pulling people. All right, time for news of the show. So I've got the first one, and this is an article entitled, you can't call yourself a senior until you've worked on a legacy project. So talking about what is a senior engineer,
我们走了相反的路。我们停止做广告了。所以这和拉人头正好相反。好了，节目新闻时间。我有第一个，这是一篇题为“在你参与过遗留项目之前，你不能称自己为高级工程师”的文章。谈论什么是高级工程师，
this is like an age old debate, whatever. Anyways, this person was kind of pointing out how they hadn't really worked on legacy code base. There's some specifics here of their thing and if you want to go read it, go to article. And the point though is pretty interesting that they kind of rightly wanted to avoid working on a legacy code base. They ended up kind of doing it, they were right, they didn't like it, but they actually learned a bunch of stuff that they didn't. And I think a couple interesting takeaways for me from the
这是一个老生常谈的辩论，随便吧。总之，这个人指出他们并没有真正参与过遗留代码库。这里有一些关于他们事情的细节，如果你想读的话，去看看文章。但重点很有趣，他们本来想避免处理遗留代码库。他们最终还是做了，他们是对的，他们不喜欢它，但他们确实学到了一堆他们没学过的东西。我觉得对我来说，从这个故事中……
story and just you know thinking on the topic is about regardless of the label of senior, like just growing as an engineer is no matter what work you're doing, finding the takeaways that are applicable. And lots of analogies, the one I've taken to using recently, just for myself and for others that I talked to about this, is like just really trying to compound the growth. So not just thinking like, hey, how do I do this thing? But like how do I think about additively like applying things I've learned before
以及思考这个话题，有几个有趣的收获，就是不管“高级”这个标签如何，作为一名工程师的成长，无论你在做什么工作，都要找到适用的收获。有很多类比，我最近对自己和与我谈论这个话题的人使用的一个类比是，真正尝试复合增长。所以不仅仅是思考，嘿，我怎么做这件事？而是，我怎么思考以累加的方式应用我以前学过的东西……
in a way that like my growth sort of grows on top of itself and you're sort of stacking it up. And sometimes you need to widen the base, right, of expanding into new things, but other times you're trying to build up and trying to apply these different experiences. And so I think partly this plays into that. And then there's an observation here specifically
以一种我的成长在自身基础上增长的方式，你正在把它堆叠起来。有时你需要拓宽基础，对吧，扩展到新事物，但有时你是在尝试建立并尝试应用这些不同的经验。所以我认为这在一定程度上与此有关。这里还有一个观察……
about legacy code bases in your place of work and understanding why maybe something isn't done that way anymore or why the stuff that you see in like the the kind of current pieces of tech are how they got there right people will say oh it's organic growth or you know whatever you of get there. But I think there is something different between saying, this is the current recommended practice and I have done it the other way and I will tell you the other way sucks, like we're doing it this way. Those two things come from slightly different places and understanding why you do something, not just, there is value in actually just not knowing, well, this is
关于你工作场所的遗留代码库，以及理解为什么有些事情不再那样做了，或者为什么你在当前技术中看到的东西是这样形成的。人们会说，哦，这是有机增长，或者你知道，无论你怎么达到那里。但我认为说“这是当前推荐的做法，我用另一种方式做过，我会告诉你另一种方式很烂，所以我们这样做”这两者之间是有区别的。这两件事来自略有不同的地方，理解你为什么做某事，不仅仅是，仅仅不知道也有价值，好吧，这是……
kind of bad, but when you get into style guidelines and stuff, right? I think just picking away and having everyone do it is, is useful because it, it really does matter. Um, but then there are things also that even if you don't always know exactly why, uh, eventually kind of figuring them out and digging in. So the one I always use, uh, in, uh, in C plus plus is the turn area operator. So you can write this Boolean expression, put the question mark, and then the thing that is true first, and then a colon, and then thing that is false if it's false second. And you can use this, and we have it banned
有点糟糕，但当你进入风格指南之类的东西时，对吧？我认为挑选出来并让每个人都这样做是有用的，因为它确实很重要。嗯，但也有一些事情，即使你并不总是确切地知道为什么，最终也会弄清楚并深入研究。所以我总是使用的那个，在 C++ 中，是三元运算符。所以你可以写这个布尔表达式，放上问号，然后是为真时先执行的东西，然后是一个冒号，然后是为假时执行的东西。你可以使用这个，我们在代码库中禁止了它。
in our code base. And the reason why is it literally does nothing unique. You can't, okay, there's like some very rare, you know, use case. Someone could come up with it, you know, in a const expression or something. But for most part, you're just simplifying writing an if-else statement. But the cognitive load to read the ternary operator, make sure you understand what it does. And that a new engineer showing up has the same practiced expertise at reading that. Like, why? Like, Like why just because features are there doesn't mean you have to use them.
原因在于它实际上没有任何独特之处。你不能，好吧，有一些非常罕见的用例。有人可能会想出来，在常量表达式之类的东西中。但大多数情况下，你只是在简化 if-else 语句的编写。但是阅读三元运算符的认知负荷，确保你理解它的作用。而且一个新来的工程师对阅读它有同样的实践经验。为什么？为什么仅仅因为有这些功能，你就必须使用它们？
And I try to explain this to people, but I would argue even not knowing my explanation and still doing it leads to good practices, but knowing why and having tried using all of the whiz bang features from the latest, you know, C++ update constantly and refactoring code just to rewrite it into those features. Having done that once and burning your hands probably
我试着向人们解释这一点，但我认为即使不知道我的解释而仍然这样做也会导致好的实践，但知道为什么并尝试使用最新 C++ 更新中的所有花哨功能，并不断重构代码以将其重写为这些功能。做过一次并烫伤了手，可能会……
teaches some lessons and so code bases can be really useful. Totally, totally agree. I mean the equivalent in Python, which is even more confusing, they have a ternary operator where you can say like x equals three if foo is true else five. So it's a ternary operator, but that you switch the first and the second position. So it's like even harder to read. And you know, oh yeah. And so I remember like,
学到一些教训，所以代码库真的很有用。完全同意。我的意思是 Python 中的等价物，这更令人困惑，他们有一个三元运算符，你可以说 x 等于 3，如果 foo 为真，否则为 5。所以它是一个三元运算符，但你交换了第一个和第二个位置。所以它更难读。而且，你知道，哦是的。所以我记得……
there was someone on my team who would do this a lot, like all over the place. And you know, I let it go. I didn't really push back on it because to your point, like it's not until you ban it, it's not banned. And so you can't really say like, don't do this because you have no like moral grounds other than your intuition.
我团队里有人经常这样做，到处都是。而且，你知道，我放任自流了。我并没有真正反驳它，因为正如你所说，除非你禁止它，否则它就不会被禁止。所以你不能真正说，不要这样做，因为你除了直觉之外没有任何道德立场。
And then it was a disaster. And so like people just kept getting burned by these like really long in line, you know, like conditions, right? And so now like I can ban it and I don't feel insecure about it or feel like hesitant about it. I don't feel like, oh, you know, it's not really against the rules. Now it's like, no, like I've done this. I've seen people like cause all sorts of issues and some issues went to prod. And so we're not doing it. Now that the one of the tough things is, you know, if you're talking to folks who don't have that experience, you have to like ban it in a way that is shows empathy and
然后那是一场灾难。所以人们不断被这些非常长的内联条件所困扰，对吧？所以现在我可以禁止它了，我不会感到不安全或犹豫。我不觉得，哦，你知道，它并没有真正违反规则。现在就像，不，我已经做过了。我见过人们导致各种各样的问题，有些问题甚至进入了生产环境。所以我们不这样做。现在，困难的事情之一是，如果你在和没有那种经验的人交谈，你必须以一种表现出同理心的方式禁止它……
doesn't like create any resentment or anything. And there is this balance that I think is useful, but often gets brushed away that bringing new folks and you actually want them to feel empowered to question. So when they see that there's a ban on this and they say, I love the ternary operator because it makes me look cool. You know, they're going to say that part, but you know, I love the ternary operator, you know, why is it banned?
并且不会产生任何怨恨。我认为这种平衡是有用的，但经常被忽视，即引入新人，你实际上希望他们感到有权质疑。所以当他们看到这个禁令时，他们说，我喜欢三元运算符，因为它让我看起来很酷。你知道，他们会说那部分，但你知道，我喜欢三元运算符，为什么它被禁止了？
I don't think it should be banned. And you actually want to take time to explain them and in some cases be willing to hear them out and maybe, you know, adapt your practice or be flexible. But in other times, like you said, I think the word confidence there is like, no, we've done this, like I hear you, but you're just going to have to trust me that like we've tried it the other way and the other way, like not banning it leads to problems. Yeah. Yeah, totally.
我不认为它应该被禁止。你实际上想花时间向他们解释，在某些情况下愿意听取他们的意见，也许，你知道，调整你的做法或保持灵活。但在其他时候，就像你说的，我认为那里的“信心”这个词是，不，我们已经做过了，我听到了，但你只需要相信我，我们尝试过另一种方式，另一种方式，不禁止它会导致问题。是的。是的，完全。
Um, yeah, I mean, I, just to wrap this up, a question I always ask in interviews, uh, if I'm doing a technical design interview, I'll always start with the question of like, tell me a time you refactored something and why did you refactor it? Like what led to the decision to do a big refactor? And that usually like opens up all sorts of interesting things because you know, people, you know, the, the worst answer is the one that totally neglects the conflict that comes from scarcity, right? It's like, you don't have enough time, but the code is garbage. And it's like, so it's like that creates conflict
嗯，是的，我的意思是，为了总结这一点，我在面试中总是问的一个问题，如果我正在进行技术设计面试，我总是会从这个问题开始，告诉我一次你重构某件事的时间，以及你为什么重构它？是什么导致了进行大规模重构的决定？这通常会打开各种有趣的事情，因为你知道，人们，你知道，最糟糕的答案是完全忽略了稀缺性带来的冲突，对吧？就像，你没有足够的时间，但代码是垃圾。所以这创造了冲突……
and then you have to resolve that conflict one way or the other. That's interesting. If someone's like, yeah, you know, I rewrote it and it was the right thing to do. And everyone agreed with me from day zero to the day I wrote it. And everyone praised me at the end.
然后你必须以一种或另一种方式解决那个冲突。这很有趣。如果有人说，是的，你知道，我重写了它，这是正确的事情。从第一天到我写它的那天，每个人都同意我的观点。最后每个人都称赞我。
It's like, okay, well, you know, that's a little unrealistic. I was gonna ask you, does anyone ever tell you, because I didn't write the code. So therefore it could of course be better. I've got that. That's how people really do, but I would be surprised if someone said it. Yeah. And people are like, oh, it was, you know, another team and that team, you know, we inherited their code and it was garbage. And so I rewrote it all. And it's like, okay, not the, not the best answer. Um, my new story is recraft might be the most powerful AI
就像，好吧，你知道，这有点不现实。我本来想问你，有没有人告诉过你，因为我没有写那段代码。所以它当然可以更好。我遇到过。人们确实是这样，但如果有人这么说，我会感到惊讶。是的，人们会说，哦，那是另一个团队，那个团队，我们继承了他们的代码，它是垃圾。所以我重写了所有东西。就像，好吧，不是最好的答案。嗯，我的新故事是 Recraft 可能是……
image platform I've ever used. Here's why. And it's a Tom's guide article. Um, honestly, like recraft is definitely the most powerful AI image system I've ever used. I found out about it yesterday. I haven't ever heard about it. Yeah, this is very, obscures is the right word,
我用过的最强大的 AI 图像平台。原因如下。这是一篇 Tom's Guide 的文章。嗯，老实说，Recraft 绝对是我用过的最强大的 AI 图像系统。我昨天才发现它。我从来没听说过它。是的，这非常，晦涩是正确的词，
but like I'm really into this stuff, like generative AI, I'm following it closely, and I hadn't heard about it until yesterday. It can do some amazing things. For one, it can produce vector art, like SVGs. Now the SVGs are... Like if you or I were to create a stop sign, for example, we'd create like a white octagon and then we'd create a red octagon inside the white octagon, and that's how we'd get a stop sign with a border around it. Right. But if you use this program, it's going to give you like a red octagon and then a bunch of white polygons around it.
但我真的很喜欢这些东西，比如生成式 AI，我密切关注它，直到昨天我还没听说过它。它可以做一些惊人的事情。首先，它可以生成矢量艺术，比如 SVG。现在 SVG 是……如果你或我创建一个停车标志，例如，我们会创建一个白色的八边形，然后在白色八边形内创建一个红色的八边形，这就是我们得到一个带边框的停车标志的方法。对。但如果你使用这个程序，它会给你一个红色的八边形，然后周围有一堆白色的多边形。
You see what I'm saying? Like it doesn't have a concept of like each edge would be. Yeah. Yeah. It's all one layer. So that's not ideal, but it's a step in the right direction. It's the only thing I've ever seen that really will give you an SVG. Like even if they're doing it post-hoc or something.
你明白我的意思吗？它没有每个边缘的概念。是的。是的。它全是一层。所以那并不理想，但这是朝着正确方向迈出的一步。这是我见过的唯一真正能给你 SVG 的东西。即使他们是在事后处理之类的。
It's extremely responsive to the prompt. So for example, one thing I've tried with a lot of these AI systems is I've said like a person holding nothing in their hand, because I'll say like a person doing XYZ and I'll get a person like holding a phone in their hand. And I'll like, and I'll type the same prompt like with nothing in their hand. And then they'll have two phones in their hand. And then it's like, it's like, it has a hard time especially with negatives. So then I'll try like a person unarmed, you know?
它对提示词非常敏感。例如，我尝试过很多这些 AI 系统的一件事是，我说过一个手里什么都没拿的人，因为我会说一个做 XYZ 的人，然后我会得到一个手里拿着手机的人。我会，我会输入同样的提示词，手里什么都没拿。然后他们手里会有两部手机。然后就像，它很难处理，尤其是负面提示。所以我尝试像一个手无寸铁的人，你知道？
So it's like, there's not like a negative there and it'll still like not work. But with this system, it's like very good at following instructions, even negatives. So it's phenomenal. The other part of it is it's got this cool workflow where you can take an image and then you can say, okay, now put a phone in their hand and it'll make like a new image of the same person with a phone in their hand, as opposed to like, you know, getting a totally different person. So it's really cool. Very, you know, easy to use, relatively cheap. So I would highly recommend folks check it out. It's pretty neat. folks check it out it's pretty neat. What are they using kind of under the hood do you know like are they using their own so some of these craft up other stable diffusion whatever you know is this like a layer on top of stuff it sounds really good but yeah this is a totally custom thing. It's a pretty big model it's a 20 billion actually the 20 billion is the v2 there's a v3 model which i think is even bigger
所以就像，那里没有负面提示，它仍然不会工作。但有了这个系统，它非常擅长遵循指令，甚至是负面指令。所以这太棒了。它的另一部分是它有一个很酷的工作流程，你可以拿一张图片，然后你可以说，好吧，现在在他们手里放一个手机，它会制作一张同一个人的新图片，手里拿着手机，而不是像，你知道，得到一个完全不同的人。所以这真的很酷。非常，你知道，易于使用，相对便宜。所以我强烈建议大家去看看。它非常整洁。大家去看看，它非常整洁。他们底层用的是什么，你知道吗？比如他们用的是他们自己的，还是其他 Stable Diffusion 之类的，你知道，这是顶层的东西吗？听起来真的很棒，但是的，这是一个完全定制的东西。这是一个相当大的模型，它是一个 200 亿参数的，实际上 200 亿是 v2，有一个 v3 模型，我想它甚至更大。
um they they're not open source so we don't really know what they're doing they might have a blog post about it i haven't seen one yet um i'm assuming it's the same type of technology where you're doing like self self-attention and then you're doing like you know masking and trying to uncover masks and whatever like the the i don't think they're really pushing the envelope on the the base model but then they built a bunch of really impressive things on top of it that's awesome i think that's one of the debates like where's the magic is it in the ui and the like you know higher level abstractions or is it in the the base, the deep stuff, you know, I don't know that we haven't answered.
嗯，他们不是开源的，所以我们真的不知道他们在做什么，他们可能有一篇关于它的博客文章，我还没看到。嗯，我假设它是同样类型的技术，你正在做自注意力，然后你正在做，你知道，掩码并试图揭开掩码之类的，无论如何，我不认为他们真的在基础模型上推动极限，但他们在它之上构建了一堆非常令人印象深刻的东西。这太棒了，我认为这是辩论之一，魔法在哪里？是在 UI 和，你知道，更高级的抽象中，还是在基础、深层的东西中，你知道，我不知道，我们还没有回答。
I think there's lots of opinions, but. I will say, I would say that I tried the Dolly. When was Dolly popular? Oh, that's, that's a four year and a half, two years ago. No, that long? I think so. The first Dolly? No, I don't know.
我认为有很多观点，但是。我会说，我会说我尝试过 DALL-E。DALL-E 什么时候流行的？哦，那是，那是四年半，两年前。不，那么久？我想是的。第一个 DALL-E？不，我不知道。
Like whenever it was making the big rounds, I feel like it was maybe two, three years ago. Oh, okay. Okay. Maybe four years ago. Anyways, I recently't know like whenever was making the big rounds. I feel like it was maybe two three years ago Okay, okay, maybe four years ago. I Anyways, I recently did download on I have a MacBook Air and I downloaded one of the like on device Stable diffusion to run flux and they just have like an app you can download So you don't have to do it the command line with Olamma or something You just like download that and it will download the model from I think a hugging facema or something, you just download that app and it will download the model from, I think a hugging face link or something. And it downloads the flux and you'll generate it
就像无论它什么时候大火，我觉得那可能是两三年前。哦，好吧。好吧。也许四年前。总之，我最近下载了，我有一台 MacBook Air，我下载了一个设备上的 Stable Diffusion 来运行 Flux，他们只是有一个你可以下载的应用程序。所以你不必用 Olamma 之类的命令行来做。你只是下载那个，它会从，我想是 Hugging Face 之类的下载模型，你只是下载那个应用程序，它会从，我想是 Hugging Face 链接之类的下载模型。它下载了 Flux，你会生成它……
and it takes, I don't know, it's like 15 to 20 seconds or something to generate an image. But it's crazy that first of this image are much better than when Dolly was making the rounds initially. You kind of wrote it off, it didn't really obey your prompts. It would make cool pictures, but anyways, so now the flux stuff and it runs like on my computer and it's free. Like the models are open source,
它需要，我不知道，大约 15 到 20 秒来生成一张图片。但疯狂的是，这些图片比 DALL-E 最初大火时好多了。你有点否定它，它并没有真正服从你的提示词。它会制作很酷的图片，但总之，所以现在 Flux 的东西，它在我的电脑上运行，而且是免费的。模型是开源的，
the program's free. So it's running locally. There's no subscription, you know, and it, you know, obviously it has to be using less power because it doesn't have an external GPU or anything. Yeah, the Flux models are super, super impressive. There's a package called M-Flux, which is flux optimized for MPS, optimized for the Apple processor. So you can use M-flux and it'll run in like half the time or a third of the time or something.
程序是免费的。所以它在本地运行。没有订阅，你知道，而且，它显然必须使用更少的功率，因为它没有外部 GPU 之类的。是的，Flux 模型非常非常令人印象深刻。有一个叫 M-Flux 的包，它是为 MPS 优化的 Flux，为 Apple 处理器优化。所以你可以使用 M-Flux，它会在一半或三分之一的时间内运行。
It's really impressive. And this re-craft thing really takes it to another level. So to your point, it'll only be a matter of time before there's an open source version of recraft. But at the moment, they have a monopoly. Well, that's another debate the open source was closed. But we'll just keep moving on. Yeah, right.
这真的很令人印象深刻。而这个 Recraft 的东西真的把它提升到了另一个水平。所以正如你所说，开源版本的 Recraft 只是时间问题。但目前，他们有垄断地位。好吧，那是关于开源还是闭源的另一个辩论。但我们继续前进。是的，对。
Open weight, yeah. Oh, oh, yeah. So, okay, no, no, no, okay. No, okay, respected. My next one is NASA has a list of 10 rules for software development. And this person is taking the sort of like publicly disclosed a list of software rules that I've bumped into before
开放权重，是的。哦，哦，是的。所以，好吧，不，不，不，好吧。不，好吧，尊重。我的下一个是 NASA 有一份软件开发 10 条规则清单。这个人正在采取那种，我以前作为嵌入式工程师在职业生涯中遇到过的公开披露的软件规则清单，
being an embedded engineer previously in my career that for writing C code, but they've tried to extend it to C++ as well, there's like a set of embedded guidelines for not doing. And this individual is taking a sort of, I'll say a kind of critique of some of them and why maybe they don't make much sense or other stuff. But if you've never seen them before,
用于编写 C 代码，但他们也试图将其扩展到 C++，有一套用于不这样做的嵌入式指南。而这个人正在采取一种，我会说一种对其中一些规则的批评，以及为什么它们可能没有意义或其他东西。但如果你以前从未见过它们，
I will say it is somewhat interesting to, and it's a lot harder if you use something like Python or Java to, I guess, derive value maybe from it, but if you've ever programmed in C or C++ before or you use Rust, probably applicable as well, or one of the other sort of systems programming languages, go kind of looking through there and seeing like how would you approach if these were your rule sets. Leaving aside, I guess this the blog post is kind of talking about how maybe the rule set could be improved or doesn't make the most sense but I'll say if someone if you showed up on a job and this was the restrictions
我会说，如果你使用 Python 或 Java 之类的东西，去推导价值可能有点困难，这有点意思，但如果你以前用过 C 或 C++ 编程，或者你使用 Rust，可能也适用，或者其他系统编程语言之一，去看看那里，看看如果这些是你的规则集，你会怎么做。撇开不谈，我猜这篇博客文章是在谈论规则集如何改进或没有意义，但如果有人，如果你在工作中出现，而这是限制，
because it was a contract that you were trying to honor like how would you accomplish this so things like never using dynamic memory allocation. And then, you know, there's kind of two approaches you end up with. One is, so I can see C++, the standard library generally just uses lots of allocation under the hood. So you end up with, you know, of course you can't use that. So some people do a lot of like static sizing of things
因为这是一份你试图遵守的合同，你会怎么完成它？所以像从不使用动态内存分配这样的事情。然后，你知道，你最终会有两种方法。一种是，所以我可以看到 C++，标准库通常在底层使用大量的分配。所以你最终会，你知道，当然你不能使用它。所以有些人做了很多像静态大小调整的事情……
up front and trying to, you know, have all of their things of an unknown size. Other people. Isn't there like a concept in C++ called an arena? Where like you define like a thousand spots? Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So then other people use a memory pool. An arena is like a kind of memory pool where they basically write their own sort of very thin sort of memory management, but it doesn't necessarily suffer from some of the same problems. And so you can use containers that adapt to that.
预先，并试图，你知道，拥有所有未知大小的东西。其他人。C++ 中不是有一个叫 Arena 的概念吗？就像你定义了一千个点？是的。好吧。是的。所以其他人使用内存池。Arena 是一种内存池，他们基本上编写自己的非常薄的内存管理，但它不一定遭受同样的问题。所以你可以使用适应它的容器。
But if you think in your head, how would you make sure that your code never did some of these things? Never had a loop that couldn't exit, right? So all loops need to have an upper bound. And just code coverage, how would that work? These kinds of things, some of them are, again,
但如果你在脑子里想，你会怎么确保你的代码从不做这些事情？从没有一个无法退出的循环，对吧？所以所有循环都需要有一个上限。还有代码覆盖率，那怎么工作？这些事情，其中一些是，再次，
pretty restrictive. Every function has to be smaller than can fit on a single piece of paper with sizing given. And it's like, well, that is probably good practice, but maybe sometimes you want to change it to be one thing or another. But it is worth reading if you've never read an embedded rule set like this before. They're not uncommon.
相当严格。每个函数都必须比能放在一张纸上的尺寸小。就像，好吧，这可能是好的做法，但也许有时你想把它改成这样或那样。但如果你以前从未读过这样的嵌入式规则集，它值得一读。它们并不罕见。
And you can occasionally, if you work in embedded space, bump into places where this is the style. There has been an explosion in processing power and real time operating systems and just the complexity and abilities of the processors. But I still think there are some places where there are probably many lines of code being written having to follow these guidelines.
而且你偶尔，如果你在嵌入式领域工作，会碰到这是风格的地方。处理能力和实时操作系统以及处理器的复杂性和能力有了爆炸式增长。但我仍然认为有些地方可能正在编写许多必须遵循这些准则的代码行。
Yeah, this is fascinating. I mean, this is a whole new universe for me. But this is really interesting. I mean, this is definitely a person who is kind of like, I think the general critique here is on C. Like this person is like, I draw that you should use another language. Yeah, like use Ada, not C. This is just a valid commentary, but yeah. All right. So my next news story is AMD Radeon RX 9070 XT performance estimates leaked.
是的，这太迷人了。我的意思是，这对我来说是一个全新的宇宙。但这真的很有趣。我的意思是，这绝对是一个人，我认为这里的普遍批评是针对 C 的。这个人就像，我建议你应该使用另一种语言。是的，比如使用 Ada，而不是 C。这只是一个有效的评论，但是的。好吧。所以我的下一个新闻故事是 AMD Radeon RX 9070 XT 性能估计泄露。
Okay, so I want to go do a little rant here. I hate kind of complaining about products. Like I feel like that's maybe like not the best use of the show, but I bought a PC, like a mini PC with a Radeon and I used it for a little while, it was okay. The drivers were really buggy. I had to go into safe mode and some stuff to get it working. But then I got it working.
好吧，所以我想在这里发泄一下。我讨厌抱怨产品。我觉得这可能不是节目的最佳用途，但我买了一台 PC，一台带有 Radeon 的迷你 PC，我用了一段时间，还可以。驱动程序真的很不稳定。我不得不进入安全模式和一些东西来让它工作。但后来我让它工作了。
You know how you can plug USB to DisplayPort or USB to HDMI? You have these cables. I don't actually know how they work under the hood, but there's some magic that allows you to go from a USB-C port to right into your display, right? I think it's like something called like display port pass through or something.
你知道你怎么能把 USB 插到 DisplayPort 或 USB 插到 HDMI 吗？你有这些电缆。我实际上不知道它们在底层是如何工作的，但有一些魔法允许你从 USB-C 端口直接进入你的显示器，对吧？我想这叫什么 DisplayPort 直通之类的。
Anyways, I plug one of these cables in, pop, the GPU blows up. Like hardware blow up dead. Yeah. Where did the it come from? It's a cable that I use in my MacBook pro. Like I've used my, I've used this cable for years. Okay. So it's the cables is fine. At least for the Mac book plugged in as many PC and it just popped. And I guess like, I mean, I'm kind of dogpiling here.
总之，我插上其中一根电缆，砰，GPU 炸了。就像硬件炸了，死了。是的。它从哪里来的？这是我在 MacBook Pro 中使用的电缆。就像我用过我的，我用这根电缆好几年了。好吧。所以电缆没问题。至少对于 MacBook 来说，插在迷你 PC 上，它就砰的一声。而且我猜，我的意思是，我有点在落井下石。
I almost feel bad, but like, you know, George Hots has this post on Twitter about this. Like he's trying to build these tiny boxes that use like that run, that run PyTorch and they use CUDA or, or, or Rockham, which is AMD's equivalent, but like the AMD, like, you know, anything above the hardware just sucks.
我甚至觉得有点不好，但就像，你知道，George Hotz 在 Twitter 上有关于这个的帖子。就像他试图构建这些运行 PyTorch 并使用 CUDA 或 Rockham（这是 AMD 的等价物）的小盒子，但就像 AMD，你知道，硬件之上的任何东西都很烂。
And it's kind of disappointing because everyone wants there to be an alternative. If nothing else, not only for price, but maybe they could do something interesting. Maybe they could make a card that has like a gigabyte of RAM and is not very fast, but just has a ton of RAM. When there's multiple people in the pond, like there's multiple ideas, right? But I was just super disappointed. I mean, I'm one of like a long line of people now who will just not buy these AMD cards. And I guess maybe just to turn this into a question, like, like how does AMD kind of like recover from this? I kind of feel like of like recover from this, I kind of feel like if I was them, I would hire like some software person, like some person who's really high up in the stack
这有点令人失望，因为每个人都希望有一个替代方案。如果没什么别的，不仅是为了价格，也许他们可以做一些有趣的事情。也许他们可以制造一张有一 GB 内存且速度不是很快，但内存很大的卡。当池子里有多个人时，有多个想法，对吧？但我只是非常失望。我的意思是，我现在是长长的一排人中的一个，他们将不会购买这些 AMD 卡。而且我猜也许只是把这变成一个问题，比如，AMD 是怎么从这个中恢复过来的？我有点觉得……如果我是他们，我会雇佣一些软件人员，比如一些在堆栈中非常高的人……
to like lead like a whole branch of the company to just like go through and just ruggedize everything from a software perspective. So I feel like this is more in your area, because when it popped, I was just shell shocked. So what causes hardware to kind of fail like that and not be tested, and what do you think you would do? Like if you were CEO of AMD, Patrick,
来领导公司的整个分支，只是去检查并从软件角度加固一切。所以我感觉这更多是在你的领域，因为当它砰的一声时，我只是被震住了。所以是什么导致硬件那样失败而不被测试，你觉得你会怎么做？比如如果你是 AMD 的 CEO，Patrick，
how would you save this? Oh my gosh. You know, as much as it's been in the news with Nvidia GPUs and stuff and the scarcity and the crypto stuff and now the AI stuff, I don't know, I'm not super up on where the profit margins come from, I know AMD of course makes processors as well, and I actually have AMD processor and GPU in the PC I built.
你会怎么拯救它？天哪。你知道，尽管它在新闻中与 Nvidia GPU 等东西以及稀缺性和加密货币东西以及现在的 AI 东西有关，我不知道，我不太了解利润率来自哪里，我知道 AMD 当然也制造处理器，而且我实际上在我构建的 PC 中有 AMD 处理器和 GPU。
And I feel like I got, you know, the Ryzen processor was like a good value for dollar over the Intel one at the time. Maybe, you know, they used to be two separate companies. Now like they're combined. I don't know how internally their company is structured, where the profit margins are on GPU. Like you said, you may say, oh, there's a large group of people who would really buy a large
而且我觉得我得到了，你知道，Ryzen 处理器在当时比 Intel 的性价比要好。也许，你知道，它们曾经是两家独立的公司。现在它们合并了。我不知道他们的公司内部结构如何，GPU 的利润率在哪里。就像你说的，你可能会说，哦，有一大群人真的会买大量的……
amount of memory, not that much processing power. But it's possible that the die costs and the spin up for that, especially when Nvidia could basically pay premium for any foundry costs because they have, you know, far more supply than demand. If you're sitting in second place, I don't know, you may be forced to basically pay more for foundry costs and things in order to be able to like, get your chips made, right? So it may make it difficult.
内存，而不是那么多的处理能力。但有可能芯片成本和启动成本，特别是当 Nvidia 可以基本上为任何代工成本支付溢价时，因为他们有，你知道，远多于需求的供应。如果你坐在第二位，我不知道，你可能被迫基本上为代工成本和东西支付更多费用，以便能够，让你的芯片制造出来，对吧？所以这可能会使它变得困难。
They may not have as much freedom as they otherwise would want. And I think the software drivers are hard as well because there's so many people you need to appease, right? You need to appease like people like you're saying, like I just wanna plug it in and get a monitor working. But then the video game people are like, I want variable frame rates.
他们可能没有他们本来想要的那么多自由。而且我认为软件驱动程序也很难，因为有太多人需要安抚，对吧？你需要安抚像你所说的人，就像我只是想插上它并让显示器工作。但游戏玩家就像，我想要可变帧率。
And then you need to appeal to the video game developers who are needing to optimize the outputs on your card and the wrappers that sit on top of it, so OpenGL or DirectX or whatever. There's all this different stuff swirling around, and I actually just feel like this, I don't even, that space just seems so complicated. I get to plug into a variety of motherboards, there's a variety of power situations, a
然后你需要吸引那些需要在你的卡上优化输出以及位于其上的包装器（即 OpenGL 或 DirectX 之类的）的游戏开发者。所有这些不同的东西都在旋转，我实际上只是觉得这个，我甚至，那个空间看起来太复杂了。我可以插入各种主板，有各种电源情况，一个……
variety of connectors, a variety of it, like the amount of compatibility you need on a GPU almost on to say like on par, probably more with than almost any other part of the PC is, is just actually bonkers. That needs to be compatible with all manner of software, all manner of OSs, all manner of hardware, internal to the computer, external to the computer. That's a lot. Maybe that stuff's all really robust and ruggedized, but I imagine just a ton of time
各种连接器，各种它，就像你在 GPU 上需要的兼容性几乎可以说，可能比 PC 的几乎任何其他部分都多，这简直太疯狂了。那需要与所有方式的软件、所有方式的操作系统、所有方式的硬件兼容，计算机内部的，计算机外部的。那很多。也许那些东西都很健壮和加固，但我想象只是大量的时间……
to get nailed down exactly right. Yeah, that's a really good call out. I wonder, and also like a lot of these things are very thankless. It's like the guy who makes sure that you could plug the USB-C to display port versus the... Because I had this machine working, display port to display port. So I know that the machine worked, but then as soon as I plugged in this other way, I heard a audio pop and it was done.
才能完全确定下来。是的，那是一个非常好的呼吁。我想知道，而且像很多这些事情是非常吃力不讨好的。就像那个确保你可以插上 USB-C 到 DisplayPort 而不是……的人。因为我让这台机器工作了，DisplayPort 到 DisplayPort。所以我知道机器工作了，但一旦我以这种其他方式插上，我听到了音频砰的一声，它就完了。
So like you have to have a person to like test all these different ways. And then like, unless it breaks, that person is not adding any value. Like they're just reducing risk and you don't know what's risky, what's not risky. So this is one of these things, it's almost like a really high level
所以你必须有一个人来测试所有这些不同的方式。然后，除非它坏了，否则那个人没有增加任何价值。他们只是在降低风险，而你不知道什么是冒险的，什么不是冒险的。所以这是这些事情之一，它几乎就像一个非常高级的……
of kind of performance management, like value of the company kind of thing that you have to fix. And then on your specific issue, I mean, it could be a faulty card that, you know, hopefully they would want to replace. And then the question is, if you did it again with the same cable with the new card, would it happen again? I don't know.
性能管理，公司价值之类的事情，你必须修复。然后关于你的具体问题，我的意思是，它可能是一张有缺陷的卡，你知道，希望他们会想要更换它。然后问题是，如果你用新卡用同样的电缆再做一次，它会再次发生吗？我不知道。
I mean, if I would, I wouldn't risk it, but like, there's two failure modes there. There's a failure mode of an individual card, and then there's a design flaw that like every card where you did that, it would sort of break. And I don't, from where I am, I just don't know enough about which specific problem it is. But certainly, like you said, it makes people have very bad sentiment.
我的意思是，如果我会，我不会冒险，但就像，那里有两种故障模式。一种是单张卡的故障模式，另一种是设计缺陷，即你那样做的每张卡都会坏掉。而且我，从我所在的地方，我只是不知道关于哪个具体问题足够多。但当然，就像你说的，它让人们有非常糟糕的情绪。
But even if you look at the, and again, not knocking, but like the Nvidia consumer cards that were having like the plug you plug into the GPU to give it extra power directly from your power supply had so much power going through it that they were like melting, they need to like have it keep pulling on it. Like, again, like you said, this is sort of thankless,
但即使你看看，再说一次，不是批评，而是像英伟达的消费级显卡，那些需要直接从电源插上额外供电线的显卡，流经的电流太大了，导致它们像是在融化，它们需要保持电流持续供应。就像你说的，这是一种吃力不讨好的工作，
right, the dude or dudette who is trying to like design the interface for some wire, copper cable to come in and deliver power. And all of a sudden they never, anyone ever thought about them in their whole entire lives. And now they're like, you know, front page of social media because these expensive graphics cards are melting. You know, oh man, this is going to be a distraction with the distraction.
对吧，那个试图为某种铜线接口设计供电方案的哥们或姐们。突然之间，他们这辈子从来没被人关注过。而现在，他们成了社交媒体的头条，因为这些昂贵的显卡正在融化。天哪，这会分散注意力，分散了原本的注意力。
But like one thing that's really interesting is like what jobs are of that sort? Where like if you do a good job, nobody cares. Or like if you do a good job, nobody notices. And what are the jobs? Because it feels to me like in every career, there exists like maybe that's, maybe I'm trying to stretch too far here. In many careers, there exists, like maybe that's, maybe I'm trying to stretch too far here.
但有一点非常有趣，就是这类工作到底是什么样的？就是那种如果你做得好，没人会在意。或者说如果你做得好，没人会注意到。这些工作是什么？因为我觉得在每个职业中，都存在这样的工作，也许我这么说有点牵强。在许多职业中，都存在，也许我这么说有点牵强。
In many careers, there exists like jobs where you get praised for doing a good job and nothing happens if you do nothing. So like jobs where you're trying to like bring in more business or raise the profit of a company or something. And then there's, there's jobs where like you're trying to keep the lights on. And so people are kind of, it's really hard for people not to ignore you until something goes wrong. It feels like there's these two kinds of jobs. And it feels to me like the former is almost always like, better than the latter in terms of like your satisfaction and a lot of other things. I was having this conversation and I won't give the details because it'll make it sound like a political statement one way or another and not trying to make it.
在许多职业中，确实存在一些工作，如果你做得好会得到表扬，但如果你什么都不做，也不会发生什么。比如那些试图为公司带来更多业务或提高利润的工作。然后还有一些工作，比如你只是在维持现状。所以人们很难不忽视你，直到出了问题。感觉这两种工作确实存在。而且我觉得前者在满意度和其他很多方面几乎总是比后者要好。我之前在进行这个对话，我不会透露细节，因为这听起来会像是一种政治声明，我并不想那样。
But anything where you're, and in this case, it was government officials, but anything you're dealing with a probabilistic event. So something may happen, may not happen. Even if it happens, the certainty isn't well known, right? You think like weather forecasting, you know, whatever, like. Yeah. And when you get it right, it's sort of like, no one, you
但任何涉及概率事件的事情，在这种情况下是政府官员，但任何你处理概率事件的情况。也就是说，某事可能会发生，也可能不会发生。即使发生了，确定性也不高，对吧？你想象一下天气预报，诸如此类。是的。当你做对了，就像是，没人，你
could just do nothing, right? And it would probably just be fine. And then that one time, you know, it's, it's out of standard deviations, like very high. And then everybody's like, why did you do? And it's like, well, it's true. Probably could have done better or done these other things, but you could have been doing those other things every single time and it either still wouldn't have made a difference or wouldn't have been relevant. And so to your point, anytime you're dealing with something where, you know, like think preparing for a holiday rush on a server that's doing e-commerce, right?
本来可以什么都不做，对吧？而且可能也会没事。然后那一次，你知道，它超出了标准差，非常高。然后每个人都问，你为什么这么做？就像是，好吧，确实。可能本来可以做得更好或者做其他事情，但你每次本来都可以做那些其他事情，要么仍然不会有任何改变，要么根本不相关。所以回到你的观点，任何时候你处理的事情，你知道，比如考虑为电子商务服务器的假日高峰做准备，对吧？
You could spend tons of money like building up, you know, extra CDNs and having flexible compute and then, you know, like people come, they shop, there's no outages, no one knows if you did a great job or a bad job, but it didn't crash. So like there's that, but if it crashes, certainly you're getting hauled in and told how much millions of dollars you lost the website, right?
你可以花大价钱建立额外的 CDN 并拥有灵活的计算能力，然后，你知道，人们来了，他们购物，没有停机，没人知道你做得好还是不好，但它没有崩溃。所以有这种情况，但如果它崩溃了，你肯定会被叫去问话，告诉你让网站损失了多少百万美元，对吧？
Yeah, I mean, it's pretty tragic that, you know, things are just set up that way, but I don't know if there's not any clear solution or anything. All right. Well, book of the show. Book of the show. What's your book?
是的，我的意思是，事情就是这样设置的，这确实很悲剧，但我不知道是否有什么明确的解决方案。好了，节目推荐书。节目推荐书。你推荐什么书？
All right. My book, this is going to be a little bit different, but I've not been reading as much as I should or I want to, but I did just start because I have never read any books by this author before and I often see it recommended in science fiction. So I decided I'm going to read a book and tried to find the recommendation and this is the recommendation I got and that is a book by Ian M. Banks and I chose The Player of Games. Have you read any Ian M. Banks books? I have not. Okay, yeah, neither have I. So I am trying to embark on reading this one. Apparently some of the
好的，我的书，这会有点不同，但我读的书没有我应该读的或我想读的那么多，但我确实刚开始读，因为我以前从未读过这位作者的任何书，而且我经常在科幻小说中看到它被推荐。所以我决定读一本书，并试着寻找推荐，这就是我得到的推荐，那是伊恩·M·班克斯的一本书，我选择了《游戏玩家》。你读过伊恩·M·班克斯的任何书吗？我没有。好的，是的，我也没有。所以我正试图开始读这一本。显然有些
books can be a little hard to read which is okay. But this one people are saying is a good introduction. There's not, from what I've seen online without trying to read any spoilers, apparently there's not like a strong order you need to read the book since. It's not necessarily the first book. But it is an often recommended one. So I'm starting here. That's not really a good recommendation because I don't know whether to tell you it's good or bad other than every other person I saw on the internet. This seemed to be bubbling to the top
书可能有点难读，这没关系。但人们说这一本是一个很好的入门书。据我在网上看到的，在不试图阅读任何剧透的情况下，显然不需要按照严格的顺序阅读这本书。它不一定是第一本书。但它是一本经常被推荐的书。所以我从这里开始。这算不上什么好的推荐，因为我不知道该告诉你它是好是坏，除了我在互联网上看到的其他人。这似乎是
as a good starting place. So I'm embarking on a journey here. Cool, that sounds awesome. Yeah, I might check that out. I have a few books queued up that I have to get to and then I'll check that out. My book of the show is Basic Role-Playing Universal Game Engine which is a reference book. It's
一个很好的起点。所以我正在踏上一段旅程。酷，听起来很棒。是的，我可能会去看看。我排队有几本书要读，然后我会去看看。我节目推荐的书是《基本角色扮演通用游戏引擎》，这是一本参考书。它
written by a couple of people who have been making tabletop games for their whole adult lives and they've made a bunch of them. I think some of them even from like the 70s and the 80s so it's bunch of them. I think some of them, even from like the 70s and the 80s, so it's kind of wild. I mean, some of the stories of the of the creators, but, but basically they synthesized. So there's this question in general, like think about any art form. You always think about like, what is the essence of this art?
是由几个在成年生活中一直制作桌面游戏的人编写的，他们制作了很多游戏。我想其中一些甚至来自 70 年代和 80 年代，所以这很疯狂。我的意思是，一些创作者的故事，但是，基本上他们进行了综合。所以一般都有这个问题，比如考虑任何艺术形式。你总是会想，这种艺术的本质是什么？
You know, like you might as an artist, like draw a bunch of things and then think to yourself, OK, what is like the essence? Like if I had to reduce something to its like most basic form, what would that be? And so these guys got together and thought, well, if we had to reduce these tabletop games, because there's a lot of like lore built into it, you know, like so many games have magic missile. Why? Because Dungeons and Dragons 1.0 had magic missile, but like what really is a magic missile? I guess it's like an arrow made out of magic, right? Or something, but like, you know, pair these things down to their essence and, and just explain like it literally like the first, the first page of the book is like the point of an RPG is for your players to have fun.
你知道，作为一名艺术家，你可能会画很多东西，然后对自己想，好吧，本质是什么？如果我必须把某样东西简化到最基本的形式，那会是什么？所以这些人聚在一起想，好吧，如果我们必须简化这些桌面游戏，因为里面有很多传说，你知道，很多游戏都有“魔法飞弹”。为什么？因为《龙与地下城》1.0 版有魔法飞弹，但到底什么是魔法飞弹？我想它就像一支由魔法制成的箭，对吧？或者类似的东西，但是，你知道，把这些东西剥离到它们的本质，并且，只是解释，就像字面上一样，书的第一页写着，RPG 的意义在于让你的玩家玩得开心。
So it's like, you know, it's like, let's start from like the first principle. The first principle is that people should be having fun. And it kind of builds up. And so it's a combination of an instruction guide to making a game engine and a reference manual of like, here's a list of like hundreds of skills from like all these skill based games we've ever seen. I've kind of to be honest been skipping over a lot of the, you know, here's a list like of like a million different types of armor because it's not what I'm interested in. And what I'm interested in is like,
所以就像是，你知道，让我们从第一性原理开始。第一性原理是人们应该玩得开心。它以此为基础构建。所以它既是制作游戏引擎的说明指南，也是一本参考手册，列出了我们在所有这些基于技能的游戏中见过的数百种技能。老实说，我跳过了很多，你知道，这里列出了一百万种不同类型的盔甲，因为那不是我感兴趣的。我感兴趣的是，
how do people create these game engines and how do they keep them balanced and how do they keep them interesting? And so when I say game engine, just to be clear, it is programming throwdown, but this has nothing to do with programming. It's literally like the math that like, you could use this for like a card game
人们是如何创建这些游戏引擎的，他们如何保持平衡，以及如何保持它们的趣味性？所以当我提到游戏引擎时，为了清楚起见，这是《编程速成》，但这与编程无关。它字面上就像数学，你可以把它用于纸牌游戏
or a tabletop game or really anything. It's like the math that keeps people kind of on the edge of their seat, right? So it's like how do you have all these different options for your players but still keep them kind of on the edge of their seat? And at the same time, how do you do that in a minimalist fashion where it's not like, okay, I'm now gonna have to roll like 45 dice to like build my character or whatever.
或桌面游戏，或者真的任何东西。它就像让人们坐在座位边缘的数学，对吧？所以它是如何为你的玩家提供所有这些不同的选择，但仍然让他们保持在座位边缘？同时，你如何以极简主义的方式做到这一点，而不是像，好吧，我现在必须掷 45 次骰子来构建我的角色之类的。
So these people tackle a lot of that. And I'm about, I wanna say maybe about halfway through, as I said, skipping a lot of the pure reference stuff. And it's really interesting. I'm having a really good time reading it. I've never played an in-person tabletop RPG or even, I mean, I probably played a video game that somewhere
所以这些人解决了很多这样的问题。我大概读了一半，正如我所说，跳过了很多纯参考资料。这真的很有趣。我读得很开心。我从来没有玩过面对面的桌面 RPG，甚至，我的意思是，我可能玩过某个视频游戏，在
under the hood was running some sort of like role checks and chance checks or something. I learned the other day, a spoiler, something I'm gonna talk about in a few minutes, that Pokemon was actually doing that when the Pokeball rattles, it's doing like a, you know, probability check and it can fail at each of the things. And then that's when the Pokemon came out, which I didn't know.
底层运行着某种角色检查和机会检查之类的东西。我前几天了解到，剧透一下，我几分钟后会谈到的一件事，宝可梦实际上在做那个，当精灵球摇晃时，它在做某种，你知道，概率检查，它可以在每一项中失败。然后那就是宝可梦出来的时候，我以前不知道。
And maybe I'm completely wrong, but that's sort of like what the internet was telling me, which is in line to your point with rolling a dice and getting certain values. But never had the occasion to play one, but I'm endlessly fascinated by, like you said, the sort of crafting of the stories and the storytelling and the fact that it's a less game than, you know, a board game with rigid rules and more about, like you said, having an adventure together, making it fun and entertaining and collaborate, like collaboratively doing something which is somewhat still gaming but is also you are sort of being flexible on the fly as well to you know keep it fun. Yeah exactly yeah exactly
也许我完全错了，但这有点像互联网告诉我的，这与你掷骰子并获得特定数值的观点一致。但我从来没有机会玩过，但我对你所说的故事创作和叙事方式，以及它与其说是一个游戏，不如说是一个有着严格规则的棋盘游戏，更多的是关于你所说的，一起冒险，让它变得有趣和娱乐，协作做某事，这在某种程度上仍然是游戏，但你也在某种程度上灵活应变，以保持乐趣。是的，完全正确，是的，完全正确。
like how do you let each person at the table have a unique character that brings something unique while still like being able to handle a person not being there. It's like, oh, you know, Jim's wife is having a baby, so this chest has to stay locked. It was the one at the keys. He's sleeping in the inn. Yeah, or he's the only one with lock picks or something. Yeah, so the book is really interesting.
比如你如何让桌上的每个人都有一个独特的角色，带来独特的东西，同时还能处理某人不在场的情况。就像，哦，你知道，吉姆的妻子要生孩子了，所以这个箱子必须保持锁着。他是唯一有钥匙的人。他正在旅馆里睡觉。是的，或者他是唯一有开锁工具的人之类的。是的，所以这本书真的很有趣。
I'd recommend folks check it out. If nothing else, it's a nice book to have on your coffee table, because it has kind of a provocative title, Universal Game Engine. All right, well, I spoiled it, but tool of the show for me is a video game, and I, for whatever reason,
我建议大家去看看。至少，它是一本放在咖啡桌上不错的书，因为它有一个相当挑衅的标题，《通用游戏引擎》。好了，我剧透了，但我节目的工具是一个视频游戏，我，不管什么原因，
skipped every modern Pokemon video game. And so I think the last one I actually legit played was when I got Pokemon Red in my Game Boy as a child and played that to no end using, and I was trying to describe this to my kids, and I had to go to, when we would go shopping, I liked the Walmart or Kmart, and I would look in the strategy guide for why I was stuck.
跳过了每一款现代宝可梦视频游戏。所以我认为我真正玩过的最后一款是小时候在 Game Boy 上玩《宝可梦红》，并玩得不亦乐乎，我试图向我的孩子们描述这一点，我不得不去，当我们去购物时，我喜欢沃尔玛或凯马特，我会查看攻略指南，看看我为什么卡住了。
And so I would go with my mom so I could go to the, you know, video game section and like open the strategy guide and like, look, because I wouldn't just buy it. I probably should have just bought it. But anyways, I didn't go home and, you know, get through anyway. So so Pokemon, right? Anyways, I've been aware I've, you know, dabbled various times, but I hadn't really sat down and played,
所以我经常和妈妈一起去，这样我就可以去视频游戏区，打开攻略指南，看看，因为我不会直接买它。我可能应该直接买的。但无论如何，我没有回家，无论如何还是通关了。所以宝可梦，对吧？无论如何，我一直都知道，我（你知道）断断续续地玩过几次，但我并没有真正坐下来玩过，
but I was sitting down and playing Sword and Shield. I was playing the Shield variant, but not super important on the Switch. And I just hadn't done that in a really long time. And I know it's a pretty big departure for the series, but it was really kind of fun. Like I was really into it. I realized now that the game is easy, like it's not supposed to be challenging
但我坐下来玩了《宝可梦：剑/盾》。我玩的是《盾》版本，但在 Switch 上这并不重要。我真的很久没这么做了。我知道这对该系列来说是一个很大的背离，但这真的很有趣。我真的很投入。我现在意识到游戏很简单，因为它不应该是具有挑战性的
to actually, you know, quote unquote beat the game. So it's not that much of an accomplishment, but not a great time. And if you've ever been interested and you, you know, have a switch or whatever, we definitely recommend checking out one of the newer ones, sword and shield. I guess the other one I'm going to try now is Scarlet. Scarlet and I think violet it is. Um, but. Pearl or something. Uh, yeah.
去真正，你知道，所谓的“通关游戏”。所以这算不上什么成就，但不是一段美好的时光。如果你曾经感兴趣，并且你（你知道）有 Switch 之类的，我们绝对建议去看看较新的版本之一，《剑/盾》。我想我现在要尝试的另一个是《朱》。《朱》和我想是《紫》吧。嗯，但是。珍珠之类的。嗯，是的。
Okay. I did. Or that's a different, I think Pearl. I think that's a remake. I think that's a remake. Oh, okay. They did like a remake. Yeah.
好的。我做了。或者那是不同的，我想是《珍珠》。我想那是重制版。我想那是重制版。哦，好的。他们做了一个重制版。是的。
Like, uh, so anyways, if you hadn't checked one of those out, they definitely went and some of them, like a little bit more with open world sections and you can kind of control how often you get into a battle versus you know just wandering around in a set of grass until it happens. So definitely some quality of life improvements over the old ones that make it less frustrating and you know ability to save sort of everywhere you want. If you never checked one out I guess this is me telling you the obvious thing of like, it's a thing and it's, it's kind of fun. Yeah. I played it with my kids and, uh, it's been maybe a year or two and, and, you
就像，嗯，所以无论如何，如果你没有看过其中之一，他们绝对去做了，而且其中一些，像开放世界部分更多一点，你可以控制你进入战斗的频率，而不是（你知道）只是在草丛里徘徊直到它发生。所以绝对比旧版本有一些生活质量的改进，使它不那么令人沮丧，并且（你知道）能够在你想要的任何地方保存。如果你从来没有看过，我想这是我在告诉你显而易见的事情，比如，它是一个东西，而且它（它）很有趣。是的，我和我的孩子们一起玩过，嗯，已经有一两年了，而且，嗯，
know, they would, uh, get frustrated. And so I'd help them like, kind of optimize their characters a little bit. Um, but more or less they could get through it eventually. And yet the other thing is it's all the bosses and everything. As far as I know, they have static levels. So, you know if if you're kind of like like my kids are just running around kind of aimlessly for a while so their pokemon were like super over leveled and that made the game even easier than if you're
他们会（嗯）感到沮丧。所以我帮他们（嗯）稍微优化了一下他们的角色。嗯，但多多少少他们最终还是能通关。还有另一件事是所有的 Boss 和其他一切。据我所知，它们有静态等级。所以，你知道，如果如果你的等级像我的孩子们一样，只是漫无目的地跑了一会儿，所以他们的宝可梦等级超级高，这使得游戏比你
trying to like speed run it but yeah that game is awesome I think uh I think the open world added a lot actually, like being able to really like see the enemies and they run into you physically and then the fight starts. Like that really added a lot, I think. Yeah, and I think that it goes crazy deep though. Once you like look on the internet, there's all this like each Pokemon you catch has different stats and there's a Rotoma.
试图（像）速通它时更容易，但是的，那个游戏太棒了，我认为（嗯）我认为开放世界实际上增加了很多，比如能够真正看到敌人，他们物理上撞到你，然后战斗就开始了。我觉得这真的增加了很多。是的，而且我认为它非常深入。一旦你（像）在互联网上查看，你抓到的每只宝可梦都有不同的属性，还有一个 Rotoma。
I never paid attention to it other than like it has a type and certain moves or whatever. Very basic level strategy and that was fine to get through the game. But when you look online you find out, oh yeah the competitive stuff and people playing online and whatever that each Pokemon you catch has like different base stats that have been rolled for that character. I mean it's not actual dice but probabilistically generated and so some are better than, even if they're the same level. All right. So Patrick, do you want me to waste hours and hours of your life? Is it going to be fun?
我从来没有注意过它，除了它有类型和某些招式之类的。非常基础的策略，这对于通关游戏来说已经足够了。但当你上网查看时，你会发现，哦，是的，竞技内容和人们在线玩之类的，你抓到的每只宝可梦都有不同的基础属性，这些属性是为那个角色随机生成的。我的意思是，这不是真正的骰子，而是概率生成的，所以有些比其他的更好，即使它们是同一等级。好的。那么帕特里克，你想让我浪费你生命中的几个小时吗？这会很有趣吗？
It's going to be fun. Okay. So, uh, later on go on YouTube. Okay. There's this guy who really understands the Pokemon mechanics and purposely. So there's a, there's a Pokemon, I think it's a web based game. It's probably not legal. It's probably already shut down or something, but there are maybe it's
这会很有趣。好的。所以，嗯，稍后去 YouTube 上看看。好的。有个家伙非常了解宝可梦机制，并且故意这样做。所以有一个，有一个宝可梦，我想是一个基于网页的游戏。它可能不合法。它可能已经被关闭了之类的，但有，也许它是
sanctioned out at a, but there's this web based game where you can just do Pokemon battles with other people. And there's a, the ELO like for chess and everything, you rise up the ranks. And so it's, it's literally just a battling part of Pokemon. And so, um, this guy who really understands the mechanics, he makes builds that are very unintuitively strong and he plays people who, um, uh, and he must play a lot of people, but inevitably he ends up playing someone who, who starts off like making fun of him and like, Oh, like you just have one Pokemon.
被批准的，但有一个基于网页的游戏，你可以在那里和其他人进行宝可梦对战。有一个像国际象棋一样的 ELO，你提升排名。所以它，它字面上只是宝可梦的对战部分。所以，嗯，这个非常了解机制的家伙，他制作了非常反直觉的强大构建，他与那些（嗯）嗯，他一定和很多人玩过，但不可避免地他最终会和一个开始（像）嘲笑他的人玩，哦，就像你只有一个宝可梦。
Like why didn't you build the other four Pokemon? Haha. You're so trash or whatever. And then he wrecks them and they start raging and they start like, and then they won't make their final moves and he's like, Hey, your time's running out. And they just get so pissed and everything. It's like the people who get the scammers upset or whatever. It's that, but for gaming trolls and it is hilarious.
就像你为什么不构建另外四个宝可梦？哈哈。你真是垃圾之类的。然后他摧毁了他们，他们开始愤怒，他们开始（像），然后他们不会做出最后的动作，他说，嘿，你的时间快到了。他们只是变得非常生气之类的。这就像那些让骗子心烦意乱的人之类的。就是那样，但针对的是游戏喷子，这太搞笑了。
Oh dear, okay. Now you have to send this to me, but I feel like I'm gonna not like you for doing it. Yeah, I mean, I don't know how many videos he has. I'm pretty sure I've watched like five or six of them. They're really, really funny. I'm pretty sure I've watched like five or six of them. They're really, really funny. Okay.
天哪，好的。现在你必须把它发给我，但我感觉我不会因为你这么做而喜欢你。是的，我的意思是，我不知道他有多少视频。我很确定我已经看了五六个了。它们真的，真的很有趣。我很确定我已经看了五六个了。它们真的，真的很有趣。好的。
All right. So, oh, my tool of the show is features and labels or fowl.ai. There's a bunch of alternatives. There's together.ai, there's fireworks.ai, there's a bunch of them. But basically these are people who are kind of a middleman between you and the AI models So they'll host the open source ones
好的。所以，哦，我节目的工具是 features 和 labels 或 fowl.ai。有很多替代品。有 together.ai，有 fireworks.ai，有很多。但基本上这些人是介于你和 AI 模型之间的中间人，所以他们会托管开源模型。
They'll often have agreements with the closed source ones so you can run like the Google image and you know, it's you Otherwise you'd have to use some proprietary Google API or whatever. So you think of these like a middle layer and they often charge you you know, per thing that you do versus like you having to rent a machine for an hour, right? The thing that, that, so the reason I picked FAL is I actually know the founders. So I, I'll just put it right out there and say, I don't know if FAL is any better than any of the other ones, but the user interface is really nice. They have like a playground mode where you can just build things on the web. And then you can click on the API button and get the Python code if you wanted to
他们通常会与闭源模型达成协议，这样你就可以运行像 Google 图像之类的东西，你知道，它是你，否则你必须使用一些专有的 Google API 之类的。所以你把这些看作是一个中间层，他们通常会向你收取（你知道）你所做的每件事的费用，而不是像你必须租一台机器一小时，对吧？那件事，那，所以选择 FAL 的原因是我实际上认识创始人。所以我，我会直接说出来，我不知道 FAL 是否比其他任何一个更好，但用户界面真的很好。他们有一个像游乐场模式的东西，你可以在网页上构建东西。然后如果你想的话，你可以点击 API 按钮并获取 Python 代码
make that programmatic. The other thing they did, which I thought was really clever UX, you know, as engineers, especially as people who have GPUs or maybe an M2 MacBook or something, we think to ourselves like, yeah, I mean, I should just run Flux myself. Like Patrick's run Flux, I've run Flux, right? But when you go to Fowl, they're like, yeah, so you can run this model like 87 times for a dollar. Like basically for every model, it tells you how many times you can run it for a dollar and that to me is like really powerful because like often like I have some code
使之程序化。他们做的另一件事，我认为是非常聪明的 UX，你知道，作为工程师，特别是作为拥有 GPU 或 M2 MacBook 之类的人，我们对自己想，是的，我的意思是，我应该自己运行 Flux。帕特里克运行过 Flux，我也运行过 Flux，对吧？但当你去 Fowl 时，他们就像，是的，所以你可以用一美元运行这个模型 87 次。基本上对于每个模型，它都会告诉你你可以用一美元运行它多少次，这对我来说真的很强大，因为（像）通常（像）我有一些代码
that I have right now and I have a local version of Flux and then I have the foul version of Flux and you can just like toggle between one and the other and and you know like I'll want to run sometimes I'll think I'll run the local version because I'm going to work like I'll want to run, sometimes I'll think, oh, I'll run the local version because I'm going to work and I'll just let it run and it'll be done when I get back. But then I'm like, yeah, it'll be done when I get back or I could spend like $7 and this is just like done in like a second.
我现在有，我有一个本地版本的 Flux，然后我有一个 foul 版本的 Flux，你可以（像）在两者之间切换，而且（你知道）我会想运行，有时我会想我会运行本地版本，因为我要去工作（像）我会想运行，有时我会想，哦，我会运行本地版本，因为我要去工作，我会让它运行，当我回来时它就完成了。但后来我想，是的，当我回来时它就完成了，或者我可以花 7 美元，这就像在一秒钟内完成。
So it's like, they did a good job of kind of like really laying out the economics, which are themselves startling, you know, how the economics have changed for AI. But they just put it right out there. And they recently had something, they had something where they they're able to do some caching of the, I think, caching of the tiles. The way the image transformers work is, you know,
所以就像，他们做得很好，真正列出了经济性，这本身就很惊人，（你知道）AI 的经济性是如何改变的。但他们只是直接把它摆出来。而且他们最近有一些东西，他们有一些东西，他们能够对瓦片进行一些缓存，我想，瓦片的缓存。图像转换器的工作方式是，你知道，
breaks your image up into tiles. And I think they're caching tiles that are very similar or something. I don't know. It's something I don't remember off top of my head, but it made the price even cheaper. So I guess long story short, check out these folks. They're all awesome. I know the fireworks people too. All these services are great I know the fireworks people too, that all these services are great and there's an economy of scale that you can really take advantage of. Yeah, I mean, I think all of it from like, someone was asking me with 3D printing, how much would it cost you to print this? You know, I saw it in a shop or something and I was like, well, most obvious thing is how much plastic it takes. But then you start thinking about it. There's depreciation of your machine, like wear and tear on your machine.
把你的图像分解成瓦片。而且我想他们正在缓存非常相似的瓦片之类的。我不知道。这是我不记得的事情，但它让价格变得更便宜了。所以我想长话短说，去看看这些人。他们都很棒。我也认识 fireworks 的人。所有这些服务都很棒，而且有一种规模经济，你可以真正利用它。是的，我的意思是，我认为这一切，从（像）有人问我 3D 打印，打印这个要花多少钱？（你知道）我在商店里看到了它之类的，我就想，好吧，最明显的事情是它需要多少塑料。但后来你开始思考它。有你机器的折旧，像机器的磨损。
There's like the power to run it. There's my time to like walk out. Mine's in the garage. Like walk out to the garage and like get it off or clean the, you know, bill plate. And so I think what you're saying is interesting too, that running it locally to me is, I guess I just cheat by, I don't want to give places my credit card. I don't know.
有（像）运行它的电力。有我走出去的时间。我的在车库里。像走到车库，把它拿下来或清理（你知道）构建板。所以我认为你所说的话也很有趣，在本地运行它对我来说是，我想我只是通过（我不）想把我的信用卡给这些地方来作弊。我不知道。
And I have stuff and so I feel like I should use the stuff I have. But you're right. Like by the time you factor in the power to run it, like it's not free and you know, your computer getting hot and the time taken. And so the economies of scale, these really big, you know, server clusters dedicated to this AI stuff, it's really kind of amazing even with how expensive those really high end GPUs are. Yeah, yeah, totally.
而且我有东西，所以我感觉我应该使用我拥有的东西。但你是对的。就像当你考虑到运行它的电力时，（像）它不是免费的，而且（你知道）你的电脑变热以及所花费的时间。所以规模经济，这些真正的大型（你知道）致力于 AI 东西的服务器集群，即使考虑到那些高端 GPU 有多贵，它也真的很令人惊奇。是的，是的，完全正确。
I think running it yourself is great. Everyone should learn how to do it. Definitely not discounting that, but check out these folks and there's similar folks too. It's a really neat service. If you have something that you then say, oh, I need to run this like 200 more times. Um, you know, your time is also really important. So, um, all right, on to our topic reinforcement learning.
我认为你自己运行它很棒。每个人都应该学习如何做。绝对不是不重视这一点，但去看看这些人，也有类似的人。这真是一个很棒的服务。如果你有某样东西，然后你说，哦，我需要再运行它 200 次。嗯，（你知道）你的时间也非常重要。所以，嗯，进入我们的主题强化学习。
Um, so a bit of background here is like the opposite of like assembly language show where in this case like this is my background, my area that I know a lot about. I'll kind of dive into it and then Patrick is going to play the role of you folks and stop me anytime I say something that is a buzzword in my community or doesn't make sense or something. So I'll start really broad. There's basically three types of AI. There's supervised learning, there's unsupervised learning, and there's reinforcement learning. So supervised learning is where you have the right answer is right there. So, so someone gives you a picture and they draw a box around the stop sign. They're like, there's the stop sign.
嗯，所以这里的一点背景是像汇编语言节目的反面，在这种情况下（像）这是我的背景，我非常了解的领域。我会深入探讨它，然后帕特里克将扮演你们的角色，每当我提到我们社区中的流行语或说不通的东西时，就阻止我。所以我从非常广泛的角度开始。基本上有三种类型的 AI。有监督学习，有无监督学习，还有强化学习。所以监督学习是你有正确答案就在那里。所以，所以有人给你一张照片，他们在停车标志周围画了一个框。他们就像，那是停车标志。
And your job is to learn a function that maps the picture to the bounding box of the stop sign. And you're given a lot of these as ground truth, right? the stop sign and you're given a lot of these as ground truth, right? And then you're also given a second set that you're purposely not meant to train on called the holdout set. And if your training did really well, then you're able to interpolate between all the other stop signs that could exist in the universe. And so after training, if I was to give you a new image you've never seen before with a stop sign in it, you could draw the box around the stop
而你的工作是学习一个将图片映射到停车标志边界框的函数。你被给予了很多这样的作为基本事实，对吧？停车标志，你被给予了很多这样的作为基本事实，对吧？然后你还被给予了第二组，你故意不打算在上面训练，称为保留集。如果你的训练做得非常好，那么你就能够对宇宙中可能存在的所有其他停车标志进行插值。所以训练后，如果我要给你一张你从未见过的带有停车标志的新图片，你可以在停车标志周围画出框。
sign. That's supervised learning. And under the hood that works through what we call a loss function. So a loss function takes the output of your model. So in this case, maybe it's a bunch of hypothetical bounding boxes. It takes the ground truth, which is the actual bounding box, and it turns all of that into a number where the further the number is away from zero, the worse you got, the worse you did. And so a zero loss would be perfectly nailed that bounding box. Now a zero loss might not be good, right? Because you want the model to have some uncertainty. Like for example, imagine we're playing paper
那是监督学习。在底层，这是通过我们所谓的损失函数来工作的。所以损失函数获取你模型的输出。所以在这个例子中，也许是一堆假设的边界框。它获取基本事实，也就是实际的边界框，并将所有这些变成一个数字，数字离零越远，你做得越差。所以零损失将是完美地钉住了那个边界框。现在零损失可能并不好，对吧？因为你希望模型有一些不确定性。比如，想象我们在玩剪刀石头布，对吧？你出布，我以 100% 的确定性出剪刀。这实际上并不好，对吧？因为虽然我在这个游戏中赢了，（你知道）我们知道一个 100% 的时间出剪刀的人并没有玩出最优的剪刀石头布，对吧？你可以，你可以学习那个，然后只是出，嗯，等等，我弄错了吗？无论如何，（你知道）这个类比，你可以只是出任何克制我刚才所说东西的东西，然后就赢了，对吧？
rock scissors, right? And you play paper and I play scissors with like 100% certainty. That's actually not good, right? Because although I won in this game, you know, we know that someone who plays scissors a hundred percent of the time is not playing an optimal paper rock scissors, right? You could just, you could learn that and then just play, uh, wait, did I get it wrong? Anyways, you know, the analogy, you could just play whatever counters what I just said, and then just win, right?
所以，所以通常你会输出一个混合答案，对吧？答案的分布。所以你总是会有一定量的损失。嗯，但是通过（通过）所谓的学习率，你不会在每次呈现一个例子时就完全改变你的思维路线，对吧？你只是在呈现例子时缓慢地向不同的方向移动，如果学习率足够低，并且所有其他一百件事都对齐了，那么你将创造出像混合，你
So, so often you're going to output a mixed answer, right? A distribution of answers. And so you're always going to have some amount of loss. Um, but through, through what's called the learning rate, you don't like totally change your line of thinking every time an example is presented, right? You're just slowly moving in different directions as examples are presented and if the learning rate is low enough and all the hundred other things kind of stars align then you will create like a mixed, you
（你知道）一个最优的混合响应。所以这就是监督学习。我做对了吗？关于那部分有什么问题吗？或者这说得通吗？所以你说，我唯一的问题是你刚才说的，所以这说得通，你有你试图匹配的东西，然后你在别的东西上进行测试，但你说在结果之间进行插值，但这应该是可能的，即使是监督学习，对我来说并不严格意味着在给定的点之间，
know, a mixed response that is optimal. So that's supervised learning. Did I get that right? Any questions about that part of it? Or did that make sense? So you said, the only question I had is you were saying, so this makes sense that you have the thing that you're trying to match and then you're tested on something else, but you said interpolate between the results, but it should be possible even with supervised learning, not strictly like interpolation to me means like between the points given,
但你应该甚至像在你的停车标志例子中，就像你提到的对于新的停车标志，想法是希望你也应该理解那些应该是放在它们周围的重型边界框。是的，对吧？所以你希望的是你可以想象一个流形，像一个停车标志空间。在那个空间里，有（像）一大堆不同种类的停车标志。
but you should even like in your stop sign example, like you were mentioning for stop signs that are new, the idea is hopefully you would also understand that those should be heavy bounding boxes put around them. Yeah, right. So what you're hoping is that you could imagine like a manifold, like a stop sign space. And in that space, there's like a whole bunch of different kinds of stop signs.
所以在那个空间里，有看起来非常不同的停车标志。但希望它们（像）它们在你已经见过的停车标志空间内。所以像一个没有发生外推的例子是，我们已经在 Waymo 上看到了这一点，人们会穿一件带有停车标志的 T 恤，那不是它，所以这是一个外推的例子。在这种情况下，模型真的不知道该做什么。所以它，它，它认为它是一个停车标志。所以，所以真的，所以有一个关于所谓的越界（嗯）检测和越界预测的整个领域。长话短说，
And so inside of that space, there's stop signs that like look really different. But hopefully they're like, they're within the space of stop signs that you've already seen. So like an example where extrapolation doesn't happen is so we've seen this with Waymo where people will wear a t-shirt with a stop sign on it and that's not it so that's an example of extrapolation. And in that case, the model doesn't really know what to do. So it, it, it thinks it's a stop sign. So, so really, so there's a whole area around what's called out of bounds, um, detection and out of bounds prediction. And long story short,
这是一个非常，非常困难的话题，但非常重要。但默认情况下，监督学习将在一个非常高维的空间中进行插值，对吧？在你看到的所有这些东西之间进行插值，但如果你给它一些全新的东西，它会有麻烦。明白了。好的，所以无监督学习是你没有损失的地方。
that's a very, very hard topic, but really important. But by default, supervised learning will interpolate at a really high dimensional space, right? Interpolate between all these things that's seen, but if you give it something totally new, it's gonna have trouble. Got it. Okay, so unsupervised learning is where you don't have a loss.
就像没有基本事实，但你确实拥有的是某种无状态且易于评估的东西。所以像最常见的例子是聚类。所以通常没有（像）已知的完美聚类。比如你可能有数百万份文档，你想把它们分成一千个簇，每个簇有 3000 份文档。而且你希望每个簇的熵非常小。
Like there's not a ground truth, but what you do have is something that's kind of stateless and easy to evaluate. So like the most common example is clustering. So there often isn't like known a perfect clustering. Like you might have millions of documents and you wanna break them into a thousand clusters, each one having 3000 documents. And you want the entropy of each of those clusters to be really small.
所以你希望它们都（像）非常靠近。所以你可能永远不知道完美的聚类，就像你在监督学习中所做的那样，但它（像）评估起来很简单。所以我可以（像）给你一组簇，你可以把文档放入簇中并返回一个分数。这个聚类有一个七分的分数，
So you want all of them to be like really close together. So you might never know the perfect clustering, like you do at supervised learning, but it's like trivial to like evaluate. So I can like show you a set of clusters, you could put the documents in the clusters and come back with a score. This clustering has a score of seven,
然后我可以做一些改变。他们说，哦，这个聚类有一个八分的分数。它好一点。那做一些改变。聚类有一个九分的分数，等等，等等。所以这就是无监督学习的一个例子。所以你甚至不是真的试图找出聚类的最佳方式。
then I can make some changes. They say, oh, this clustering has a score of eight. It's a little better. That makes some changes. Clustering has a score of nine, et cetera, et cetera. And so that's an example of unsupervised learning. And so you're not even really trying to figure out the best way to cluster.
（像）人类在做那个，但计算机只是（像）遵循指令，然后随着时间的推移得到越来越好的聚类。你可以衡量这一点。所以你可能永远无法达到最优，但你可以更接近。所以无监督学习在某种意义上更棘手，因为你没有基本事实。现在强化学习在我看来是这些领域中最难的，
Like a human is doing that, but the computer is just kind of following the instructions and then over time getting a better and better clustering. And you can measure that. And so you might never get to the optimal, but you can get closer. So unsupervised learning is a little bit trickier in a sense that you don't have a ground truth. Now reinforcement learning is in my opinion, the hardest of these areas,
不是说你必须是最聪明的人才能做到这一点之类的，但最难的是在获得良好结果方面是最困难的。这是因为你拥有无监督学习的所有挑战，你没有完美的围棋游戏或完美的国际象棋游戏作为参考，但你也在做决定。在无监督学习的情况下，你并没有真正做任何决定。
not in terms of you have to be the smartest to do it or anything, but the hardest in terms of getting good results is the most difficult. And this is because you have all the challenges of unsupervised learning, where you don't have a perfect game of go or a perfect game of chess to reference, but you also are making decisions. In the unsupervised learning case, you're not really making any decisions.
有一个人类在做决定或一个人类编写的算法在做决定，而你只是在评估它们。但在这里你必须做决定。所以它就像，这是一组簇。我如何让它们变得更好？然后你做那个，然后它们真的变得更好了吗？所以如果你实际上是在现场用 AI 设计你自己的聚类算法，那么那就是强化学习。
There's a human making decisions or a human written algorithm making decisions and you're just evaluating them. But here you have to make the decision. So it's like, here's a set of clusters. How do I make them better? And then you do that and then did they actually get better? So if you were actually on the fly designing your own clustering algorithm with AI, then that's reinforcement learning.
但当我们从高层说（像）哦，Flux 或这个或那个之类的东西时，我们谈论的东西，它可能正在使用用各种这些技术训练的组件或使用各种这些技术，对吧？所以不一定是一个整体，我不知道那里的区别是什么，（像）一个整体程序应用程序是这些之一。你有点像在较低的层面说话。你说（像）管道的那一部分是这样做的。有点像。所以，嗯，在 Flux 的情况下，那全是监督学习。
But the stuff that we talk about when we say at a high level like, oh, flux or this or whatever, it may be using components that were trained with a variety of these techniques or use a variety of these techniques, right? So it's not necessarily that a whole, I don't know what the distinction there is, like a whole program application is one of these. You're sort of talking like a little lower level. You're saying like one part of that pipeline was done this way. Kind of. So, uh, so in the case of flux, that's all supervised learning.
所以在 Flux 的情况下，它被称为自监督学习，其中在 Flux 的情况下，它被称为自监督学习，你隐藏图像的一部分，你要求 AI 画出它。然后因为你隐藏了它，你知道它过去是什么。所以你把它展示给 AI 并说，嘿，（你知道）这个像素实际上应该是红色的，但你画了紫色之类的。所以，是的，所以那是纯监督学习。有（像）（你知道）最近一些，所以另一种说法是强化学习（像）做事情，（像）采取行动
So in the case of flux, it's what's called self supervised learning where In the case of flux, it's what's called self-supervised learning where you hide part of an image and you ask the AI to draw it. And then because you hit it, you know what it used to be. And so you show that to the AI and say, hey, you know, this pixel actually should be red, but you drew purple or something. And so, yeah, so that's pure supervised learning. There are like, you know, recently some, so another way of saying it is reinforcement learning like does stuff, like takes actions
而监督学习和无监督学习（像）揭示知识。所以在停车标志的情况下，（你知道）在停车标志周围画边界框（像）揭示或合成了知识。就像现在你从像素变成了那里有一个停车标志，但它没有告诉你如何，它不驾驶汽车或转动相机或采取任何行动。所以一旦你想采取行动，现在要么人类必须编写该代码。但一旦你想让 AI 采取行动，现在要么人类必须编写该代码，但一旦你想让 AI 采取行动，现在你就在做强化学习。
and supervised learning and unsupervised learning kind of reveal knowledge. So in the case of the stop sign, you know, drawing the bounding box around the stop sign kind of reveals or synthesizes knowledge. Like now you went from pixels to there's a stop sign there, but it doesn't tell you how to it doesn't drive a car or turn a camera or take any action. So as soon as you want to take an action now, either the humans have to write that code. But as soon as you want AI to take an action, now either the humans have to write that code, but as soon as you want AI to take an action, now you're doing reinforcement.
监督学习和无监督学习揭示了知识。以停车标志为例，在停车标志周围画出边界框揭示或综合了知识。现在你从像素层面知道了那里有一个停车标志，但这并不能告诉你如何驾驶汽车、转动摄像头或采取任何行动。因此，一旦你想采取行动，要么必须由人类编写代码。但一旦你想让AI采取行动，要么必须由人类编写代码，但一旦你想让AI采取行动，你就是在进行强化学习。
So there's a bunch of different kinds of reinforcement learning algorithms, but there's basically two axes that you need to think about. One is offline versus online. And this is just a fancy way of saying, can I make mistakes? So for example, the AI that plays go, um, alpha go in the beginning of training, um, let's just stick with alpha goes zero. It's all pure reinforcement learning. So in the beginning of training, it's just playing garbage games of Go. And that's fine because it's playing against itself and it's, it's, you can't embarrass the computer. So, so it just plays garbage games
强化学习算法有很多种，但你只需要考虑两个基本维度。一个是离线，一个是在线。这只是一种花哨的说法，意思是：我能犯错吗？例如，下围棋的AI，比如AlphaGo，在训练初期——我们以AlphaGo Zero为例——它完全是纯粹的强化学习。在训练初期，它下的全是垃圾棋局。这没关系，因为它是在和自己对弈，你没法让电脑感到尴尬。所以，它只是在下垃圾棋局。
of Go and it gets better and better. But like you couldn't, for example, like drive a self-driving car randomly until it got better. Like, you know, you can't do that. You'd crash the car, people would die, be like total mess, right? So offline reinforcement learning is where whenever you make decisions in the real world, they have to come with some kind of guarantee. In the case of online reinforcement learning, you can just make decisions in the real world whenever you want at any point. And so that's like a subtle difference, but it has like pretty big consequences and algorithms and everything else. and algorithms and everything else. So online it's able to change itself and like update
它下得越来越好。但是，你不能让自动驾驶汽车在变好之前随机驾驶。你知道，你不能那样做。你会撞车，人会死，那将是一团糟，对吧？所以，离线强化学习是指在现实世界中做决策时，必须有某种保证。而在在线强化学习中，你可以随时随地在现实世界中做决策。这是一个微妙的区别，但在算法和其他方面却有着巨大的影响。所以在线学习能够改变自身并进行更新。
and then offline it's sort of like you're wanting to make guarantees, you wanna know like, I understand what it's gonna do, I've tested it in some way and I don't want it sort of like changing what it's doing. Right, right. So online you're willing to put any model in production. So yeah I think it's sometimes they call it on policy versus off policy but it gets the nomenclature there doesn't matter as much. Those are the two kinds. Um, okay. And so then there's a second axis or second kind of switch here, which is value and value based or policy based.
而离线学习则更像是你想要做出保证，你想要了解它会做什么，你已经以某种方式测试过它，并且你不希望它改变自己的行为。没错，没错。所以在线学习时，你愿意将任何模型投入生产。我想有时人们称之为“同策略”（on-policy）与“异策略”（off-policy），但术语并不那么重要。这就是两种类型。好的，那么这里还有第二个维度或第二个切换点，即基于价值（value-based）或基于策略（policy-based）。
So I'll go into this. So, um, let's say you have to make some decisions, right? And when you go to make a decision, like imagine a choose your own adventure book. And whenever you go to make a choice, I was to tell you, like, if you make this choice, you have like this percent chance of reaching the best ending. And if you make this choice, you have this other percent chance. Like you would just choose the highest percent. Right. And you would just do that. It would be like solving a maze with no walls, right? You would just, you just like pick the highest percent every time until it's a
我来深入讲讲。假设你必须做一些决定，对吧？当你去做决定时，就像想象一本“选择你自己的冒险”书。每当你做出选择时，如果我告诉你，如果你做出这个选择，你有多少百分比的机会达到最好的结局。如果你做出那个选择，你有另一个百分比的机会。你会选择百分比最高的那个。对吧。你就会那样做。这就像在没有墙的迷宫里寻找出路，对吧？你每次都会选择百分比最高的那个，直到达到百分之百，然后你就赢了。对吧。
hundred percent and then you would win. Right. And so the idea with value-based reinforcement learning is if I know the total value of a decision and I know that for all my choices, then I've solved the problem. I just picked the one with the highest value and that's just the optimal policy. And so value-based kind of ignores the whole decision part of it somewhat and says the game here really is figuring out the expected value because once I have that I'm set. Now here's where it gets tough, right? Is let's say AlphaGo places a stone somewhere on the go board to start the game.
基于价值的强化学习的核心思想是：如果我知道一个决策的总价值，并且我知道所有选择的价值，那么我就解决了这个问题。我只需要选择价值最高的那一个，这就是最优策略。所以基于价值的方法在某种程度上忽略了决策本身，认为这里的游戏本质上是计算期望价值，因为一旦我得到了那个，我就万事大吉了。现在难点来了，对吧？假设AlphaGo在围棋棋盘上放了一颗棋子来开始游戏。
And it's playing itself or some other world champion or something, right? It places that stone and its value is about.5. It has like a 50-50 chance of winning the game when it just started, right? Well, let's say I, Jason, go and play the world champion of Go. And I put the same stone in the same position, just coincidentally, for my first move.
它在和自己或其他世界冠军对弈，对吧？它放下了那颗棋子，它的价值大约是0.5。它刚开始时有50%的胜算，对吧？好吧，假设我，Jason，去和围棋世界冠军对弈。我碰巧在第一步把同样的棋子放在了同样的位置。
I have a 0% chance of winning, right? Because I'm not even close to a world champion. I'm going to get wrecked. Right. So so you have this paradox where like the value is based on a policy. But if the policy is based on the value, you can see how this is like a cyclical reason. Reasoning. Right. And so getting the value is actually really, really hard for this reason. And there's
我获胜的几率是0%，对吧？因为我根本不是世界冠军的对手。我会输得很惨。对吧。所以你遇到了这样一个悖论：价值是基于策略的。但如果策略又是基于价值的，你可以看出这是一种循环推理。对吧。所以出于这个原因，获取价值实际上非常非常困难。而且有
several algorithms. The simplest one is called SARSA, which basically says you make a bunch of moves, the game ends or the episode ends, you stop driving the car or whatever it is, then you just go back and you know what happened. So you assign the expected value. So, you know, I turn the steering wheel here, I turn the steering wheel there, I hit the brakes, I hit the gas, and then I made it home safe. Therefore, all those actions are plus one, right? You know, turn the steering wheel, I hit the gas, I crash into a wall. Therefore, all those actions are plus one, right? You know, turn the steering wheel, I hit the gas, I crash into a wall. Therefore all those actions are minus one. And then, uh, you feed that into your neural network.
几种算法。最简单的一种叫SARSA，它基本上是说你做了一系列动作，游戏结束或回合结束，你停止驾驶汽车或无论什么任务，然后你回过头来看发生了什么。所以你分配期望价值。所以，我知道我在这里转了方向盘，在那里转了方向盘，我踩了刹车，我踩了油门，然后我安全到家了。因此，所有这些动作都是加一分，对吧？你知道，转动方向盘，我踩了油门，我撞到了墙上。因此，所有这些动作都是减一分，对吧？然后，你把这些输入到你的神经网络中。
You do, uh, your training and, um, um, that's pretty simple. Um, you know, that completely ignores the thing we just talked about. There's other algorithms like Q learning and stuff that try to address some of these challenges. Um, it's really difficult. Um, it's not, doesn't mean value optimization doesn't have its place, but you know, ignoring the, the, the policy makes the, makes it really difficult to optimize it's good in situations where like,
你进行训练，这很简单。你知道，这完全忽略了我们刚才谈到的问题。还有其他算法，比如Q-learning等，试图解决其中一些挑战。这真的很难。这并不是说价值优化没有用武之地，但你知道，忽略策略使得优化变得非常困难。它在某些情况下很好，比如
there's clearly one good action at any given time, you just don't know what it is. Like Atari is a great example where, like the actions are binary, there's usually like one good action. Like if you're playing Mario or something and you're about to run into a Goomba, you either jump or die.
在任何给定时间都有一个明确的好动作，你只是不知道它是什么。比如雅达利游戏就是一个很好的例子，动作是二元的，通常有一个好的动作。比如你在玩马里奥，快要撞到板栗仔时，你要么跳，要么死。
And so you jump, right? But as soon as you get into environments where you need a mixed response, um, like poker or driving a car or really doing anything in the real world, it becomes difficult. Um, any questions about value optimization? Or did that, Did that make sense? So I guess it makes sense. So I think what you're in these cases, you're trying to, like you were saying, is there's
所以你跳，对吧？但一旦进入需要混合反应的环境，比如扑克或驾驶汽车，或者在现实世界中做任何事情，这就变得困难了。关于价值优化有什么问题吗？或者说，这讲得通吗？我想这讲得通。所以我想在这些情况下，你是在尝试，就像你说的，是
like understand the outcome of a game. So you're playing a game, you don't know what's going to happen. So you don't know if it's a good or bad move until sort of like it's too late. So but by observing many, many, many games to their conclusion, you're hoping that when you go to do it, I guess that's, that's offline, but for real, that you've built up an estimate of given us context, what is the likelihood that each decision is good or bad? Yeah, right. Right.
理解游戏的结果。所以你在玩游戏，你不知道会发生什么。所以直到为时已晚，你才知道这是一个好动作还是坏动作。但是通过观察许多许多许多游戏直到结束，你希望当你去执行时——我想那是离线学习——但实际上，你已经建立了一个估计：在给定背景下，每个决策是好是坏的可能性是多少？是的，没错。
And as your values improve, your policy improves, which means your values now are all inaccurate. And so you're just like kind of iterating on this over and over again. Yeah, but you're totally, you totally nailed it. Okay, so the other type of algorithm is policy optimization. And in this case, you say, at least in the most naive example, you say, I don't even really care how good this action is. Like I don't need to know what's my expected value of taking this action or anything. All I want to know is I want to take actions that are good and I don't want to take actions
随着你的价值评估提高，你的策略也会提高，这意味着你现在的价值评估又变得不准确了。所以你只是在不断地重复这个过程。是的，你完全说对了。好的，那么另一种算法是策略优化。在这种情况下，你说，至少在最简单的例子中，你说，我甚至不在乎这个动作有多好。我不需要知道采取这个动作的期望价值是多少。我只想知道，我想采取好的动作，我不想要采取
that are bad. It's like I cooked some eggs, they're delicious.'t want to take actions that are bad. It's like, I cooked some eggs. They're delicious. I want to do more of that. I touched the stove with my hand, not delicious. Don't want to do that anymore. Right? Very simple.
坏的动作。就像我煎了一些鸡蛋，它们很美味。我想多做点。我用手摸了炉子，不美味。不想再那样做了。对吧？非常简单。
So, so policy gradient is basically, and I'm going to try to do a lot of hand waving here, but basically it says, get the expected value of this action. So you do have to kind of like play out a whole series of events. But then when you go back and you look at what happened, take the things that were good, that had positive value and do more of them and do them in proportional to how positive the value was, take the things that had negative value, do less of them and do it in proportion. So things that are really negative value really do it a lot less, right? It's a very simple concept. One challenge right off the bat that you can see is
所以，策略梯度基本上是——我要尝试用很多手势来解释——但它基本上是说，获取这个动作的期望价值。所以你确实需要把一系列事件完整地演练一遍。但当你回过头来看发生了什么时，把那些好的、有正价值的事情拿出来，多做一些，并且与价值的正向程度成比例；把那些有负价值的事情拿出来，少做一些，也成比例地减少。所以那些负价值很高的动作要少做很多，对吧？这是一个非常简单的概念。一个显而易见的挑战是
your expected value has to be centered at zero. Like in other words, if all you can do is get points, but you can never have a negative score, then your system is gonna say, do everything infinite amount of time, and it's just not gonna be able to learn. So you need what's called a baseline such that you hope that roughly half the time you're getting a positive score and half the time you're
你的期望价值必须以零为中心。换句话说，如果你所能做的只是得分，但永远不会有负分，那么你的系统会说，无限次地做所有事情，它将无法学习。所以你需要一个所谓的基准（baseline），这样你希望大约一半的时间你得到正分，一半的时间你得到
getting a negative score. Now for something like Go, it's trivial because you play a game and you either win or lose and so unless you're playing like someone way out of your league in either direction, you're hopefully going to win and lose about half the time. You get a negative one for losing, positive one for winning, you're all set. So Go makes this very easy. But in the real world, it doesn't work that way. And so it actually like figuring out how you can get half of the expected values to be positive is really hard. And so you actually use a second neural network just to figure that out.
负分。对于围棋这样的游戏，这很简单，因为你玩一局游戏，要么赢要么输，所以除非你和水平远超你的人对弈，否则你希望大约有一半的时间会赢和输。输了得负一分，赢了得正一分，你就搞定了。所以围棋让这变得很容易。但在现实世界中，情况并非如此。所以弄清楚如何让一半的期望价值为正真的很困难。所以你实际上需要使用第二个神经网络来计算这个。
And that's called the critic. And so the, the, if you hear the term actor critic, the actor is just a policy gradient that I talked about earlier. And the critic, all it's doing is it's trying to figure out the baseline. It's trying to figure out the average move, what would be the expected value of that, so you can subtract that out and hopefully get a balance between positive and negative. And so this is the neural network you would use on a Go board to tell you like how good your situation is?
这被称为评论家（critic）。所以，如果你听到“演员-评论家”（actor-critic）这个词，演员就是我刚才提到的策略梯度，而评论家所做的只是试图找出基准。它试图找出平均动作，找出它的期望价值，这样你就可以减去它，希望在正负之间取得平衡。所以这就是你在围棋棋盘上使用的神经网络，用来告诉你你的处境有多好？
Yeah, exactly. So if you were using Go for an example, let's say you're trying to solve Go with a policy gradient. So you would say, I took a bunch of actions, I won. Now I'm going to look at this one action. I got an expected value of one because I won the game. Now what was the average expected value? Actually, sorry, what was the advantage is what I need to know. So I need to know was this one like for example like is this am I playing someone who's like a total chump and so like even though I won I can't really
是的，完全正确。所以如果你以围棋为例，假设你试图用策略梯度来解决围棋。你会说，我采取了一系列动作，我赢了。现在我要看看这一个动作。因为我赢了比赛，我得到了一个期望值为1。现在平均期望值是多少？实际上，抱歉，我需要知道的是优势（advantage）。所以我需要知道，这个动作——例如，我是不是在和一个菜鸟对弈，所以即使我赢了，我也不能真正
learn anything right or did I play someone who's like a grandmaster and actually learned a ton by winning. That's your sort of advantage function and so you're gonna take the value function of the current state. So at this current board state, what's the probability I win? And then you're going to take the action you took and see what's the value at that state. So if the probability of winning the game is 50%, but after I took my action it jumped up to 60% then I know that taking that action like caused an extra 10% and so that's my advantage and so
学到什么？或者我是在和一个大师对弈，通过获胜学到了很多。这就是你的优势函数，所以你要取当前状态的价值函数。在这个当前的棋盘状态下，我获胜的概率是多少？然后你要取你采取的动作，看看那个状态下的价值。所以如果获胜的概率是50%，但在我采取动作后跳到了60%，那么我就知道采取那个动作带来了额外的10%，这就是我的优势。所以
you know if you're playing someone of your level half of your actions are going to cause your win probability to go down and half of them are going to cause your win probability to go up. Got it. Yeah, so as I said for go you don't need it as long as you're doing self play but for you know something like Atari where there is never a negative score you need to know like what is was a bad action and so a bad action is one where your expected score went down after you took the action. It's like, oh, I took the action to run into the Goomba and now my expected score
你知道，如果你和水平相当的人对弈，你一半的动作会导致胜率下降，一半会导致胜率上升。明白了。是的，正如我所说，对于围棋，只要你在进行自我对弈，你就不需要它。但对于像雅达利游戏这样永远没有负分的游戏，你需要知道什么是坏动作。所以坏动作就是你采取动作后期望分数下降的动作。就像，“哦，我采取了撞向板栗仔的动作，现在我的期望分数
is a lot lower because I have one less life to go and collect points with. So is there a conversion between lives and points then, or it's just simply that because you lost a life, your maximum point that you can get is reduced? It's the latter. Yeah, so all of that has to be inferred. So now you could make it explicit. So you could say, and this is something that we should talk about, it's called reward shaping. So let's say in Mario, your goal is to get the most points. But that's kind of a really weird goal, right? Because often when we play as humans, we don't even look at the score, right? So you might come up with proxy goals. You might say, well, every time I eat a, well, every time you eat a mushroom,
低了很多，因为我少了一条命去收集分数。”那么生命值和分数之间有换算吗？还是说仅仅因为你失去了一条命，你可能获得的最高分数就减少了？是后者。是的，所以所有这些都必须被推断出来。现在你可以把它明确化。所以你可以说——这是我们应该讨论的，叫做奖励塑造（reward shaping）。假设在马里奥中，你的目标是获得最高分。但这其实是一个很奇怪的目标，对吧？因为作为人类，我们玩游戏时甚至不看分数，对吧？所以你可能会想出代理目标。你可能会说，好吧，每次我吃一个蘑菇，
you get points actually. But let's pretend you did it. It's like every time I eat a mushroom, I'm going to give myself extra points. Maybe you don't get enough points for eating a mushroom. And if you gave yourself more points for eating a mushroom, then the AI learns easier. Um, and, and to your point, like you don't lose points when you die, but maybe you should, like maybe if you lost 10,000 points, every time you died, the AI would learn a lot easier. And so this is called reward shaping. It's where you, instead of learning the task at hand, you learn a new task because those two tasks kind of go up and to the right at the same time. They're correlated and the new task is just easier to learn.
实际上你会得到分数。但假设你做了。就像每次我吃一个蘑菇，我就给自己额外加分。也许你吃蘑菇得到的分数不够多。如果你给自己吃蘑菇加更多的分，那么AI就更容易学习。而且，正如你所说，你死的时候不会扣分，但也许你应该扣分，比如如果你死的时候扣掉10000分，AI会学得容易得多。这就是所谓的奖励塑造。它是指你不是学习手头的任务，而是学习一个新任务，因为这两个任务在某种程度上是同步增长的。它们是相关的，而新任务只是更容易学习。
Yeah. So I mean, I don't know the scoring of Mario either. I never paid attention I guess like you could get weird states Otherwise where you try to get a bunch of one-up mushrooms and then on a particularly high value level Like basically keep dying almost at the end repeatedly in order to like keep gaining points for that level assuming you don't lose points when you die. And so you could get this very undesired behavior because it realizes the way to get the maximum score is to keep dying and replay the level and gaining those points. When the actual thing you wanted was kind of get through the levels as fast as possible.
是的。我的意思是，我也不了解马里奥的计分方式。我从来没注意过。我想你可能会在其他情况下进入奇怪的状态，比如你试图获得一堆加命蘑菇，然后在某个高价值关卡，基本上在快结束时反复自杀，以便在该关卡不断获得分数，假设你死的时候不扣分。所以你可能会得到这种非常不理想的行为，因为它意识到获得最高分的方法是不断死亡并重玩关卡来获得那些分数。而你真正想要的是尽可能快地通关。
And you didn't really care about the score and you used it as a, but it was like a bad proxy for what you wanted. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. And then on the flip side, like you might say, well, my goal is to get as far to the right as I can. Right. But if you don't take score into account, it might just be really hard for the AI to do that. Like the AI might just like desperately do like kamikaze jumps to the right where it gets killed because it didn't, or the AI might just not be incentivized to get mushrooms and make it more survivable, that kind of stuff. So yeah, reward shaping is a really big part of the problem.
你并不在乎分数，你把它当作一个目标，但它是一个糟糕的代理目标。是的，完全正确。完全正确。另一方面，你可能会说，我的目标是尽可能向右走。对吧。但如果你不考虑分数，AI可能很难做到这一点。比如AI可能会绝望地进行向右的自杀式跳跃，导致死亡，因为它没有被激励去吃蘑菇来增加生存能力，诸如此类。所以是的，奖励塑造是问题中非常重要的一部分。
And, um, um, and so when people go from manually designing systems, like if this ad has this chance of getting liked, then put a highlight around it or something. When people like build these things by hand, they, they have to deal with like all these conflicting metrics and how do When people build these things by hand, they have to deal with all these conflicting metrics and how do you reconcile, oh, we showed more ads, but there was more kind of racy, unethical kind of photos and how do I deal with that? And so reinforcement learning moves that problem
而且，当人们从手动设计系统转向时，比如“如果这个广告被喜欢的概率是这样，那就给它加个高亮”之类的。当人们手工构建这些东西时，他们必须处理所有这些相互冲突的指标，以及如何协调——哦，我们展示了更多广告，但其中包含更多低俗、不道德的照片，我该如何处理？所以强化学习将这个问题转移到了奖励塑造阶段，但它并没有真正消除它。你总是需要越来越好地理解你的目标和问题的本质，以及如何最好地解决这个问题。好的，那么，让我们深入探讨离线部分。
to the reward shaping phase, but it doesn't really get rid of it. You're always going to need to like better and better understand kind of like your goals and the nature of the problem and how to kind of how to best like solve that problem. Okay, so, okay. So let's dive into the offline part.
所以，你知道，很多人好奇的一点是，是的，AlphaGo和自己对弈。所以最后，在你使用了数以亿计的GPU小时后，它就像一个世界冠军，但我们在现实世界中该怎么做呢？显然，婴儿不会只是撞墙或摔倒。实际上，如果你让他们摔倒，他们确实会从楼梯上摔下来，
So, you know, one thing a lot of people wonder is, yeah, like AlphaGo plays against itself. And so at the end, after you've used like a zillion GPU hours, it's like a world champion, but like, how do we do that in the real world? Like clearly like babies don't just like run into walls or like fall down. Actually they do kind of fall downstairs if you let them,
但这只是个糟糕的例子。但是，你知道，作为人类，我们驾驶汽车的方式是，有人在帮助我们，但我们并不是在随机猛打方向盘直到我们学会为止。我们有一种常识基础，我们从中汲取经验。
but that's a bad example. But like, but like, you know, as humans, like the way we drive a car is, you know, we have a person helping us, but we're not just like randomly jerking the steering wheel until we figure it out. Like we have the sort of like base of common sense, like we kind of draw from.
就像一个关于汽车应该如何工作的模型。完全正确，完全正确。我们通过大脑进行投射，我们通过观察别人开车、观察父母开车，尽可能地模拟驾驶体验。我们在第一天就建立了一个模拟。所以问题是，我们如何用强化学习做到这一点？
Like a model of how the car should work. Exactly, exactly. And we kind of like kind of project into using our mind, we kind of simulate the driving experience as best we can from watching other people drive, watching our parents drive. And we've built a simulation of that on day one. And so there's a question of like, how do we do that with reinforcement
其中很大一部分是使用所谓的“信任域”（trust region）。信任域的工作原理是这样的。假设我玩了很多局围棋。我是一个不错的棋手。我玩了很多局围棋。现在我回过头来看我所有的比赛，对吧？这只是作为人类的我。我观看我所有的比赛，我对自己说，哦，我可能本可以换一种方式下这步棋。我本可以换一种方式下那步棋，但我不会说我本可以换一种方式下每一步棋。作为一个人，
learning? And a big part of that is using what's called a trust region. And so a trust region is basically, it works like this. So let's say I play a bunch of games of Go. And I'm a decent player. I play a bunch of games of Go. And now I go back and I watch all of my games, right? This is just me as a human. I watch all of my games and I look to myself and I say, oh, I would have done maybe this move differently. I would have done that move a little differently, but I'm not going to say like I would have done every move differently. Like as a person,
我们做不到，那会让我们陷入一种非常奇怪的状态，我们根本不知道该做什么。对吧。所以我们会挑选几个关键点来做不同的处理，然后等到下一场比赛，练习这些差异，然后重复这个过程。所以，你知道，在强化学习中，如果你获取大量数据并让计算机尝试进行策略优化，
like we can't, that would put us into a really weird state where like we wouldn't really know what to do. Right. So we would pick like a few key things that we would do differently and then we would wait until it's the next tournament, exercise those differences, and then we'd repeat this process. And so, you know, with reinforcement learning, if you take a bunch of data and have computers try to do policy optimization,
它们就会产生幻觉，就像我们在ChatGPT和其他东西中看到的那样，它们会开始产生幻觉，比如“哦，如果我下这步棋，我就能得到棋盘上所有的棋子”，因为模型中存在某种不准确性。另一件事是，它只需要一个动作在正向方面不准确，就会把一切都搞砸，对吧？你所有的价值评估现在都乱了，一切都乱了，对吧？所以它本质上是不稳定的。
they'll just hallucinate, just like we see with chat GBT and these other things like they'll start hallucinating like oh If I play this move I'm gonna get every single go piece on the board because there's like some inaccuracy in the model and The other thing is like it only needs one Action to be inaccurate on the positive side to throw everything off, right? All your values are now thrown off, everything, right? So it's inherently kind of unstable.
所以信任域策略优化（TRPO）和近端策略优化（PPO）所做的，就是它们基本上说，我们将跟踪在现实世界中采取的动作以及模型正在做的事情。如果模型与现实世界不匹配的次数太多，我们将停止训练。所以，你知道，在训练初期，模型会完美匹配现实世界，因为它是同一个模型，对吧？就像你把这个模型部署到现实世界中，收集了一堆数据，
And so what trust region policy optimization and proximal policy optimization, what these things do is they basically say, we're going to keep track of the actions that were taken in the real world and what the model is doing. And if the model doesn't match the real world enough times, we're going to stop training. So, you know, in the beginning of training, the model is going to match the real world perfectly because it's the same model, right? Like you rolled this model out in the real world, collected a bunch of data,
在训练的第一个小批量（mini-batch）中，模型还没有改变。所以它会输出相同的分布，对吧？随着时间的推移，分布会开始分歧。而且因为，你知道，因为你拥有这个模型，你实际上可以跟踪整个分布，对吧？所以即使你实际上踩了油门，你知道模型对于踩油门还是不踩油门是50/50的。这就是你要记录的内容，对吧？
and at the very first mini batch of training, the model hasn't changed. And so it's going to output the same distribution, right? Over time, the distributions are going to start diverging. And because, you know, because you own the model, you can actually keep track of the entire distribution, right? So even though you actually press the gas, you know that the model was like 50, 50 about pressing the gas or not. And that's what you're going to log, right?
所以现在你正在训练，你说，哦，驾驶汽车的模型50%的时间踩了油门。但新模型想要100%的时间踩油门。这是一个很大的区别。所以也许现在是停止训练并用新模型去驾驶的好时机。所以，你知道，这背后的数学比这多得多。但实际上这就是正在发生的事情，这些就像是停止准则。
So now you're training and you say, Oh, well, the model that drove the car, press the gas 50% of the time. But the new model wants to press the gas a hundred percent of the time. That's a pretty big difference. And so maybe this would be a good time to like stop training and go drive with the new model. And so that's, you know, there's a lot more math than that. That's effectively what's going on is these are like halting, halting criteria.
所以你可能在不得不停止并回到现实世界之前，无法进行太多的训练。明白了。所以这基本上就像是你离我们所知道的太远了。所以你需要再去尝试一下。你改变了很多东西，但你的输出现在非常不同。所以我们需要再去尝试一下，看看它是否真的变好了。是的，完全正确。
So you might not be able to train that much before you have to stop and go to the real world. Got it. to train that much before you have to stop and go to the real world. Got it. So it's basically like you've you're too far away from what we know. So you need to go try again. You've changed a bunch of stuff a little, but your outputs are now very different. So we need to go try again and see if it actually got better. Yeah, exactly.
嗯，我要在这里涵盖的最后一件事，嗯，还有其他几件事。所以一个是模仿学习（imitation learning）。这很简单。这个想法是，嗯，我们谈到了监督学习，对吧？还有停车标志，对吧？但我可以用我做的决定做同样的事情，我可以告诉它，嘿，当你看到这种情况时，踩刹车，对吧？我只是作为一个专家说，这就像一个基本事实，就像，明确的，你知道，在这里踩刹车，在这里踩
Um, and then the last thing that I'll kind of cover here, um, but, uh, there's a couple of other things. So one is imitation learning. And so this is pretty simple. The idea is, um, you know, we talked about supervised learning, right? And the stop signs, right? But I can do the same thing with decisions I could say hey when you see this situation press the brake right and I'm just saying as an expert like it's a ground truth like like unambiguous you know press the brake here press
油门，这叫模仿学习，这就是监督学习。所以，你知道，你可以模仿一个人，然后所有关于插值和我们谈论的一切常规内容都适用。但这并不是真正的强化学习。这就是非Zero版本的AlphaGo，它是在所有人类比赛上训练的，他们基本上说，我们希望你模仿获胜的那个人。对吧。完全正确。所以AlphaGo把它当作一个引导阶段，然后在那之后进行了强化学习。
the gas pedal here that's called imitation learning and that's just supervised learning press the gas pedal here. That's called imitation learning and that's just supervised learning. So you know you could imitate a person and then all the regular things apply there of interpolation and everything we talked about. But that's not really reinforcement learning. And that's the AlphaGo not zero where it was trained on all the human games and they basically said, we want you to imitate the person who won. Right. Exactly. And so AlphaGo did that as like a bootstrapping phase and then did, did reinforcement learning after that.
AlphaGo Zero版本去掉了引导阶段。嗯，所以这是一个，所以模仿学习是一个很好的引导方式。这就是我们所做的。我想涵盖的另一件事是基于模型的强化学习（model-based reinforcement learning）。基本上，在AlphaGo的情况下，它可以和自己对弈，因为它只是一个游戏，对吧？
The AlphaGo zeroes where they got rid of the bootstrapping phase. Um, so that's a, so imitation learning is a good way to bootstrap. to the bootstrapping phase. So imitation learning is a good way to bootstrap and that's kind of what we do. Another thing I wanna cover is model-based reinforcement learning. We're basically, in the case of AlphaGo, it can play itself because it's just a game, right?
就像一个人工环境。但如果你想做，例如，自动驾驶汽车，正如我们所讨论的，你不能在学习如何做时随机驾驶。所以你必须构建一个模型。你必须构建一个虚拟环境，然后在那个虚拟环境内进行游戏。你知道，现在的挑战当然是，
Like it's an artificial environment. But if you want to do, for example, a self-driving car, as we talked about, you can't just drive randomly while you learn what to do. And so you have to construct a model. You have to construct like a virtual environment and then play within that virtual environment. You know, the challenge now is, of course,
当虚拟环境与真实环境不匹配时会发生什么？所以有不同的方法来处理这个问题。有一种东西叫联合嵌入（joint embedding）。但长话短说，对于基于模型的强化学习，你有这个“从模拟到现实”（sim-to-real）的问题。所以如果你搜索“sim-to-real”，你会发现成千上万篇论文，但它是
what happens when the virtual environment doesn't match the real environment? And so there's different ways to deal with that. There's something called a joint embedding. But long story short, with model-based reinforcement learning, you have this SIM to real problem. So if you look up SIM to real, you'll find like a zillion papers on it, but it's
像，你如何获取在模拟器上训练的东西并将其带到现实世界，然后来回往复？嗯，好的。要涵盖的最后一件事是策略评估（policy evaluation）。所以，你知道，在监督学习中，你有真相。所以就像，哦，我没有在停车标志周围画出边界框。那很糟糕。
like, how do you take something that was trained on a simulator and bring it to the real world and back and forth and back and forth? Um, okay. Yeah. The last thing to cover is policy evaluation. So, you know, with supervised learning, you have the truth. So it's like, oh, I didn't draw the bounding box around the stop sign. That's bad.
我在停车标志周围画出了边界框。那很好。你可以，有无数种方法来计算这些错误，但你可以用这些方法计算它们并输出结果，对吧？在强化学习的情况下，你并没有像完美的围棋比赛那样的东西。
I drew the bounding box around stop sign. That's good. And you can, there's a million different ways you want to count those errors, but you can count them those ways and just output that, right? In the case of reinforcement learning, you don't really have like a perfect game of Go or anything like that.
所以你必须做的是，你可以做几种不同的事情。你可以使用模拟器并说，哦，在模拟器中，我的模型变好了。这就是AlphaGo所做的，对吧？但在自动驾驶的情况下，也许你不想信任模拟器，你可以做另一件事，运行两个模型，第一个模型实际控制汽车。第二个模型只是说，嗯，我们称之为反事实（counterfactuals），这只是一个花哨的词，意思是“我本会这样做”。
So what you have to do is, several different things you can do. You can either use a simulator and say, oh, in the simulator, my model got better. That's what AlphaGo does, right? But in case of, let's say, self-driving, where maybe you don't want to trust the simulator, there's another thing you can do where you run two models and the first model actually controls the car. And the second model just says, well, we call counterfactuals, which is just a fancy word for I would have done this.
对吧。所以它字面上就是一个后座司机，字面上。所以，你然后采取那些反事实和实际发生的事情，你就可以弄清楚新模型是否比旧模型更好。例如，假设旧模型没有踩刹车，而新模型非常非常想踩刹车。然后半秒后，旧模型猛踩刹车。好吧，那可能本可以被新模型避免，因为新模型刹车更早，对吧？它更具预测性，对吧？所以这将是一个迹象，表明新模型是一个进步。
Right. So it's just like, it's literally a backseat driver, literally. So, so you then take those counterfactuals and what actually happened and you can figure out if the new model is better than the old one. So for example, let's say the old model doesn't hit the brakes and the new model really, really wants to hit the brakes. And then like half a second later, the old model slams on the brakes. Well, that probably could have been avoided by the new model, because the new model was breaking earlier, right? It was like more predictive, right? And so that would be a sign that the new model is a step up.
同样，如果旧模型猛踩刹车以避免碰撞，而新模型会踩油门，那是一个坏迹象。这意味着新模型可能会让你陷入糟糕的境地。所以同样，这背后有很多数学，但实际上这就是策略评估背后的直觉。关于这一点还有最后一件事，策略评估比解决问题本身更难。因为如果你有一个完美的策略评估器，那么你也有一个完美的策略。你只需要采取评估器给出最高分的动作。所以出于这个原因，就像在监督
Similarly, if the old model slams on the brakes to avoid a collision and a new model would have hit the gas, that's a bad sign. That means that new model probably would have got you in a bad position. So again, a lot of math behind that, but effectively that's the intuition behind policy evaluation. And one last thing about that is policy evaluation is harder than solving the problem. Because if you have a perfect policy evaluator, then you also have a perfect policy. You just take the action that the evaluator gives the highest score to. So because of that reason, like versus like in supervised
学习中，你可以只测量准确率，只需取你做对的次数除以总次数。非常简单，只是代数。但在这里，不仅评估策略很难，而且实际上比解决问题本身更难。在许多情况下，这是不可能的。所以这是一个巨大的挑战。而且这在今天仍然是一个挑战。
learning, you could just measure accuracy, just take the times you were right and divide it by the total time. Very easy, just algebra. But here it's like, not only is it hard to evaluate the policy, but it's actually harder than solving the problem. And in many cases, it's impossible. So that's a big challenge. And that continues to be a challenge today.
嗯，嗯，所以这就是，这就是策略。所以我已经涵盖了所有的技术内容。我会深入探讨一些大语言模型的内容，但在我这样做之前，关于技术内容有什么问题吗？所以我想我缺少的是，是，我想这是一个小应用，也就是理解。所以有些问题，正如你所说，显然不适合监督或无监督学习。所以你可以考虑，哦，也许这是一个强化学习任务。什么时候你，但有些事情也许有多种方法可以解决，所以，你知道，你可以使用强化学习，
Um, um, and so that's, that's Paul. So I've kind of covered all of the technical stuff. I'll dive into a little bit of the large language model stuff, but before I do that, any questions about the technical stuff? So I guess the thing I'm missing is, is is I guess it's a little application which is understanding So some problems like you're saying are clearly not a fit for supervised or unsupervised learning And so you could think about like oh, maybe this is a reinforcement learning task When do you but then some things maybe there's multiple approaches to solving and so, you know, you could use a reinforcement learning
你可以尝试其他方法。然后从工具箱的角度来看，即使在今天，我也可以直接谷歌你的停车标志例子，有100个教程教你如何打开TensorFlow、PyTorch，无论什么。给它图像，给它标签。我们谈到了标注，但给它标签并监控你的损失函数。
You could try something else. And then from a toolbox standpoint, even today, I can just Google your stop sign example, and there's 100 tutorials for opening up TensorFlow PyTorch, whatever. Give it the images, give it the labels. We talked about labeling, but give it the labels and monitor your loss function.
做强化学习有同样的一套工具吗？或者是否也有一些非常经典的例子，你可以去参考，来做简单的案例？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。好的，所以，好的，关于问题的第一个部分，我认为我的总体哲学是使用最简单的工具来完成工作，对吧？
Is it the same, is there like the same set of tools for doing reinforcement learning? Or is there also some really like a canonical example that you would sort of go to to like kind of do like the simple case? Yeah, it's a really good question. Okay, so, okay, the first part of the question, I think that my general philosophy is to use the simplest tool for the job, right?
所以例如，我举一个非常具体的例子。我工作过的一个地方，我可能可以说出来。我就直说吧。我不认为这会有什么争议，也不是什么大爆料，但你知道，当我在Meta工作时，我们发布了Oculus商店，对吧？所以你现在可以去Oculus商店购买Oculus Quest的游戏。对吧。所以我与产品经理交谈，他们要求与我的团队会面，
So for example, I'll give a really concrete example. There was a place I worked at, I could probably say this. I'll just say it. I don't think it's going to be that controversial or anything, but it's not that much of an expose, but you know, when I worked at, at Metta, you know, we released the Oculus store, right? And so you can go right now to the Oculus store and buy games for the Oculus Quest. Right. And so I talked to the product managers, they asked to meet with my team,
他们想做强化学习来弄清楚在店面的什么位置放置什么项目。所以当你去oculusstore.com或无论什么URL时，他们应该在那个横幅上显示什么？他们称之为“英雄位置”（hero position）。他们应该在英雄位置放什么，等等？
and they wanted to do reinforcement learning to figure out what items to put on what places on the storefront. So when you go to like oculusstore.com or whatever it is, the URL, like what should they just show right there on the banner? They call that the hero position. What should they put in the hero position, et cetera?
我的回应是，不仅你不应该使用强化学习，你甚至不应该使用AI，对吧？你应该做的是，把卖得最好的应用程序手动放在英雄位置，然后那样运行一个月。然后如果你意识到，如果你有这种直觉，哦，有这么多兴趣不同的人，我们
And my response to them was like, not only should you not use reinforcement learning, you should also not use AI, right? What you should do is like take the app that sold the most and put it in the hero position just manually and run that way for a month. And then if you realize that like, if you just have this intuition, like, oh, there's, there's so many people with so many different interests and we're
向每个人展示《节奏光剑》（Beat Saber），效果不好，所以我们需要做一些AI，那么我们再去那里。对吧。所以，最简单的工具完成工作。最简单的事情就是一个带有《节奏光剑》的YAML文件，对吧？所以他们发布了那个。然后我会说，你知道，
showing everyone beat saber and it's not going well and, and so we need to do some AI then let's, let's go there. Right. So like simplest tool for the job. Like the simplest thing was just like a YAML file with Beat Saber in it, right? And so like they launched that. And then I would say, you know,
如果你能在决策周围做一些简单的事情，比如，好的，在某些国家，我展示《节奏光剑》，在其他国家，我展示其他东西。然后现在我正在按其他人口统计数据进行划分。接下来你知道，你有点像是在手工构建决策树。好的，让我使用决策树，对吧？
if you can do something simple around the decision, like say, okay, in certain countries, I'll show Beat Saber and other countries, I'll show other stuff. And then now I'm dividing by some other demographics. And the next thing you know, you're kind of like building a decision tree by hand. Okay, let me use the decision tree, right?
然后，在某个时候，你会遇到相互竞争的利益，你知道，我希望商店表现良好，但我也希望游戏发行商分享利益。我不想只是让《节奏光剑》称王。现在我有了这个非常复杂的竞争经济模型。现在我们开始谈论强化学习和其中的一些内容。我会说坚持使用最简单的工具
And so, and then at some point you run into like competing interests where, you know, I want the store to do well, but I also want game publishers to share the benefit. I don't want to just king make big beat saber. Now I have this competing economic model that's very complex. Now we're starting to talk about reinforcement learning and some of that. I would say stick with the simplest tool
来完成工作。强化学习通常比试图手工采取行动要简单得多。所以对于运营市场，对于驾驶汽车，你知道，强化学习是一个很好的选择。是的，至于工具，工具落后太多了。这有很多原因。其中最大的原因是强化学习无法真正商品化，因为它太接近公司做出的决策，而这些决策是敏感的。所以它很难商品化。我的意思是，我们推出了Reagent，它曾一度是最受欢迎的强化学习平台。现在有OpenAI Baselines。所以有很多地方可以获取算法，对吧？但如果你想要真正的技术，比如我如何进行离线评估？
for the job. Reinforcement learning often is much simpler than trying to like take actions by hand and stuff like that. So for running a marketplace, for driving a car, you know, reinforcement learning is a great choice. Yeah, and as far as tooling, the tooling is way way behind. There's a lot of reasons for this. One of the biggest reasons is reinforcement learning can't really be commoditized because it's too close to the decisions that companies make, which are sensitive. And so it's just very hard to commoditize. I mean, we rolled out Reagent, which was the most popular reinforcement learning platform for a while. Now there's open AI baselines. So there's a bunch of places where you can get the algorithms, right? But if you want like the real techniques, like how do I do offline evaluation?
很多这些都是专有的。Reagent实际上有策略评估和所有这些。所以人们绝对可以去看看，据我所知，代码库仍然是活跃的。但我认为这个领域还太新，还没有真正好的实践。但是的，这是两个很棒的问题。好的，那么我将继续讨论RLHF。所以很多人是在ChatGPT推出RLHF时了解到强化学习的，这正是ChatGPT聊天部分的原因。是什么让它从GPT变成了ChatGPT。RLHF是一个非常简单的想法。这个想法是，所以这个想法是这样思考的。GPT是模仿学习。所以一个人写了，
A lot of these are proprietary. Reagent actually has policy evaluation and all of that. So folks can definitely check that out and the code base, as far as I know, is still active. out and the code base as far as I know is still active. But I think the field is just still too new for there to be kind of really good practices there. But yeah, those are two awesome questions. Okay, so I'll move on to RLHF. So a lot of people found out about reinforcement learning when chat GPT rolled out RLHF, which is what makes the chat part of chat GPT. What took it from GPT to chat GPT. RLHF is a pretty simple idea. The idea is So the idea is thinking about it this way. GPT is imitation learning. So a person wrote,
其中许多是专有的。Reagent实际上有策略评估等功能。所以大家绝对可以去看看，据我所知，代码库仍然处于活跃状态。但我认为这个领域还太新，还没有形成真正好的实践。不过，这两个问题问得非常好。好的，那我就继续讲RLHF。很多人是在ChatGPT推出RLHF时才了解到强化学习的，这正是ChatGPT中“聊天”功能的来源。它让模型从GPT变成了ChatGPT。RLHF是一个相当简单的概念。这个想法是，可以这样理解：GPT是模仿学习。所以是一个人写的，
the frog or the fox jumped over the dog or whatever that is. When you pick a font, it always shows you that same sentence. It's like the quick fox jumped over the lazy dog. So that's probably all over the internet, right? Because it's in every font. So GPT will imitate a human quote unquote, if a human is you know all the content on the internet averaged, right? And so if you say like the Fox, the quick Fox jumped, GPT will
青蛙或狐狸跳过了狗，或者类似的东西。当你选择一种字体时，它总是会显示那同一个句子。就像“敏捷的狐狸跳过了懒狗”。所以这可能在互联网上随处可见，对吧？因为它存在于每种字体中。所以 GPT 会模仿人类，如果你知道互联网上的所有内容都是平均的，对吧？所以如果你说像“狐狸，敏捷的狐狸跳过了”，GPT 会
respond with like over the lazy brown dog, right? And this was trained in a supervised way, but when you think about it as like it's a decision to put that token there, like it's a decision to put that word there, then actually GPT is making decisions. And so, And so it becomes a reinforcement learning problem when it becomes multi-step. So for example, you know, if I just need to predict the next word and I know exactly what it is, that's supervised learning. But if I have like 10 different answers from GPT and I want to pick the best answer, like an entire answer only gets one score, now it's a reinforcement learning problem. Because I have to figure out, okay, this answer is better than that one, therefore all the
回应说“那只懒惰的棕色狗”，对吧？这是以监督方式训练的，但当你把它看作是一个决定，即把那个标记放在那里，就像把那个词放在那里是一个决定一样，那么实际上 GPT 正在做出决定。因此，当它变成多步骤时，它就变成了一个强化学习问题。例如，如果我只需要预测下一个词，并且我确切地知道它是什么，那就是监督学习。但如果我有 10 个来自 GPT 的不同答案，而我想选出最好的答案，比如整个答案只有一个分数，现在这就是一个强化学习问题了。因为我必须弄清楚，好吧，这个答案比那个好，因此所有
tokens that generated that answer are a little bit better, but we don't know how much. And so RLHF is just a pretty simple algorithm where you say, give two answers. If the system is more likely to pick the wrong answer, it gets a negative point. It's more likely to pick the right answer, it gets a positive point, and now you do your policy gradient. to pick the right answer, it gets a positive point, and now you do your policy gradient.
生成该答案的标记都稍微好一点，但我们不知道好多少。所以 RLHF 只是一个非常简单的算法，你说，给出两个答案。如果系统更有可能选择错误的答案，它就会得到负分。如果它更有可能选择正确的答案，它就会得到正分，现在你执行你的策略梯度。选择正确的答案，它就会得到正分，现在你执行你的策略梯度。
And so RLHF has been a part of these LLMs for a very long time. The thing DeepSeq did that made reinforcement learning- Oh yeah. What is RLHF? What does it actually stand for? Reinforcement learning? Reinforcement learning from human feedback. Ah, there we go. Okay. So yeah, the person, a human is actually saying this answer is better than that one. Okay, so the thing that DeepSeek did that was pretty amazing is it took the human part out. And so it's just RLF. And so the idea is it'll generate an answer
所以 RLHF 在很长一段时间里一直是这些大语言模型的一部分。DeepSeek 所做的让强化学习——哦，是的。什么是 RLHF？它到底代表什么？强化学习？基于人类反馈的强化学习。啊，就是这样。好的。所以是的，那个人，一个人类实际上是在说这个答案比那个好。好的，所以 DeepSeek 所做的非常了不起的事情是它去掉了人类的部分。所以它只是 RLF。这个想法是它会生成一个答案
to a question that is easily verifiable. So for example, they give it a word problem and they know the steps of the word problem and they know the answer. And so they output two hypothetical answers and it comes back and says, hey, this one's better than that one, but it's all algorithmic. So in math, there's systems that are, you know, they're very expensive to run and they're very specific to math, right? They only solve math problems, but they're totally autonomous so i can give you like not just the answer like twenty or something i can give you like the whole reasoning and the answer to a word problem and the system will actually verify the entire thing. And so they replace the human feedback with this expensive system and then they ran this is only in times. system. And then they ran this a zillion times. And what they found was the model that came out of it not only could do math problems better than anything we've ever seen, but it became like
针对一个容易验证的问题。例如，他们给它一个应用题，他们知道应用题的步骤，也知道答案。所以他们输出两个假设的答案，然后它回来并说，嘿，这个比那个好，但这一切都是算法化的。所以在数学中，有些系统，你知道，运行成本非常高，而且非常针对数学，对吧？它们只解决数学问题，但它们是完全自主的，所以我可以给你，不仅仅是像“20”之类的答案，我可以给你整个推理过程和应用题的答案，系统实际上会验证整个过程。所以他们用这个昂贵的系统取代了人类反馈，然后他们运行了这个——这只是在次数上。系统。然后他们运行了无数次。他们发现由此产生的模型不仅能比我们见过的任何东西更好地解决数学问题，而且它变得像
very thoughtful and reflective. And so the reality is what they found is if you treat every question like a math word problem, then you become like much more reflective and like thought provoking and interesting in your answers. And so that's basically what the DeepSeek folks have done, which is definitely like a huge leap forward and really exciting. Does that part make sense? The RLF part of it? Yeah, I think it makes sense. I think they're, but ultimately they're going back and tuning the output of what the LLM is doing or they're tuning something that comes after the LLM. Yeah, no, they're modifying the LLM? Yeah, no, they're, they're modifying the LLM itself and all these cases. Okay.
非常深思熟虑和反思。所以现实情况是，他们发现如果你把每个问题都当作数学应用题来对待，那么你在回答时就会变得更加反思、更具启发性和趣味性。所以这基本上就是 DeepSeek 的人们所做的，这绝对是一个巨大的飞跃，非常令人兴奋。那部分有道理吗？RLF 的部分？是的，我觉得有道理。我想他们是，但最终他们是在回去调整大语言模型输出的内容，或者他们是在调整大语言模型之后的东西。是的，不，他们是在修改大语言模型？是的，不，他们在所有这些情况下都在修改大语言模型本身。好的。
Yep. So, so if you think about it, like regurgitating the next token is, is actually a form of imitation learning. So you're saying like these humans that have written this stuff on the internet, they're experts and I'm trying to out, do the same action they're doing where action is writing letters.
是的。所以，如果你考虑一下，像复述下一个标记实际上是一种模仿学习。所以你是说这些在互联网上写这些东西的人是专家，而我正试图做他们正在做的同样的操作，其中操作就是写字母。
And so then when I change the goal to be like, solve this reinforcement learning problem, it's still like a set of actions. And so you can use the same model. Oh, another thing I should mention is, we talked about actor critic, and we talked about how to get this policy gradient stuff to work, you need to have positive
所以当我把目标改为“解决这个强化学习问题”时，它仍然是一组操作。所以你可以使用同一个模型。哦，我应该提到的另一件事是，我们谈到了演员-评论家模型，我们谈到了如何让这些策略梯度工作，你需要有正
values half the time, negative values half the time. So the challenge here is these models now are huge, right? Like these LLMs are enormous. And so if you need a second enormous LLM, then that's going to be really problematic. And so what they did, which is really interesting, um, and, and, uh, it actually only works because there's no intermediate rewards, uh, but that's kind of a detail. Um, is they said, okay, we can't afford to have a second model so what we're going to do is we're going to get the expected value of all these different
值一半的时间，负值一半的时间。所以这里的挑战是这些模型现在非常巨大，对吧？这些大语言模型非常庞大。所以如果你需要第二个庞大的大语言模型，那将是非常成问题的。所以他们所做的，非常有趣，嗯，而且，呃，它实际上之所以有效，只是因为没有中间奖励，但这算是一个细节。嗯，是他们说，好吧，我们负担不起第二个模型，所以我们要做的就是我们要获得所有这些不同
answers to this math problem so we're going to generate ten answers we're going to get the expected value of all ten of them and then we're going to get, and then we're going to basically normalize that number. So for example, I get the expected value of all 10 answers, and let's say the expected value is all 1, except for the 10th answer, which is 2. So I'm just going to normalize that so that all the ones become like negative 0.8 and the two becomes positive 0.8 or something like that. So they replaced like an entire neural
答案对这个数学问题的期望值，所以我们要生成十个答案，我们要获得所有十个答案的期望值，然后我们要获得，然后我们要基本上对那个数字进行归一化。例如，我得到所有 10 个答案的期望值，假设期望值都是 1，除了第 10 个答案，它是 2。所以我只是要对其进行归一化，使所有的 1 变成负 0.8，而 2 变成正 0.8 之类的。所以他们用一些简单的代数取代了整个神经网络
network with some simple algebra and so that's the GRPO or group relative policy optimization. So it's one of these things that's like a really clever trick. I have kind of mixed feelings about it. I do think that with intermediate rewards, it's going to struggle. I think that maybe coincidentally or maybe on purpose, but the fact that in this particular domain, you just get a reward at the very end is one of the important causes for this approach working over like PPO or these other alternatives. Another interesting thing where they've kind of diverged is generally what people have done in
，这就是 GRPO 或组相对策略优化。所以这是那种非常聪明的技巧之一。我对它有种复杂的感觉。我确实认为，如果有中间奖励，它会很吃力。我想也许是巧合，也许是有意的，但在这个特定领域，你只在最后得到奖励，这是这种方法比 PPO 或其他替代方案有效的重要原因之一。另一个有趣的事情是他们已经分道扬镳了，通常人们在
situations like this where you need a large actor model and a large critic model is they've had the two share the same backbone. So for example you have a neural net where the current state of your of your universe goes into the net and then the neural network outputs two things. It outputs the distribution of actions you should take, that's your actor output. And then it outputs the expected value of the current state, that's your critic output.
这种情况下，当你需要一个大型演员模型和一个大型评论家模型时，他们会让两者共享同一个骨干网络。例如，你有一个神经网络，你的宇宙的当前状态进入网络，然后神经网络输出两件事。它输出你应该采取的操作分布，那是你的演员输出。然后它输出当前状态的期望值，那是你的评论家输出。
And so you still just have one model, it just has one tiny extra output on it. So you might say to yourself, well, that's like pretty awesome, right? I mean, that seems like a no brainer. But the problem is that even though it's just adding one node, both of those nodes are sharing that network. And so they're kind of competing with each other.
所以你仍然只有一个模型，它只是多了一个微小的额外输出。所以你可能会对自己说，嗯，那太棒了，对吧？我的意思是，这看起来是个不用动脑筋的事。但问题是，即使只是增加了一个节点，这两个节点都在共享那个网络。所以它们在某种程度上是在相互竞争。
You know, the critic model is going to be steering the entire network towards producing better values. The actor model, actor part of the model is going to be steering the network to producing a better policy and they're going to be causing corruption in each other. And so although you will see like people have success with this for Atari and other domains. I think it's actually super destructive and my guess is that the DeepSeek folks tried to have like just one network, one single network that does the policy and the actor, sorry, the actor and the critic in just one network. And they realized that doesn't work, that it just causes corruption
你知道，评论家模型将引导整个网络产生更好的价值。演员模型，模型的演员部分将引导网络产生更好的策略，它们会导致彼此的腐败。所以虽然你会看到人们在雅达利和其他领域用这个取得成功。我认为这实际上是极具破坏性的，我的猜测是 DeepSeek 的人们尝试过只用一个网络，一个单一的网络来执行策略和演员，抱歉，演员和评论家都在一个网络中。他们意识到这行不通，它只会导致腐败
and it just never converges and it just is a mess. And so they ended up falling back to this approach where they said, okay, well, we can't have a separate critic model. It's too big. and it just is a mess. And so they ended up falling back to this approach where they said, okay, well, we can't have a separate critic model, it's too big. We can't put a critic head on the LLM because that causes too much corruption. And so we're just gonna abandon the entire idea of a critic and just come up with baselines on the fly.
而且它永远不会收敛，简直是一团糟。所以他们最终回到了这种方法，他们说，好吧，我们不能有一个单独的评论家模型。它太大了。而且简直是一团糟。所以他们最终回到了这种方法，他们说，好吧，我们不能有一个单独的评论家模型，它太大了。我们不能在大语言模型上加一个评论家头，因为那会导致太多的腐败。所以我们只是要放弃评论家的整个想法，并在运行中想出基准。
And that worked for them, which is really cool. Was that something that was unexpected? Like, was that like a sort of, I don't know, I call it like an innovation to make that leap? Or was it just sort of like, no, it was pretty obvious once I got there. Yeah, so this is where it gets interesting is, I mean, so there's a lot of theories. So I'll say, you know, I, you know, I'm not at Metta anymore. I don't work at OpenAI or these places. And so I don't, you know, I don't really know like what's on the very cutting edge that
这对他们来说很有效，这真的很酷。那是意料之外的事情吗？就像，那是一种，我不知道，我称之为一种实现这一飞跃的创新吗？还是说，不，一旦我到了那里，这就很明显了。是的，这就是有趣的地方，我的意思是，有很多理论。所以我说，你知道，我，你知道，我不在 Meta 了。我不为 OpenAI 或这些地方工作。所以我不知道，我真的不知道什么是处于最前沿的，
hasn't been released to the public. There's speculation that OpenAI was already doing something like this, but they hadn't published it. And so DeepSeek kind of scooped it. There's even more like, even more speculative is the idea that somebody stole the idea from OpenAI and gave it to DeepSeek. That is pure speculation. But I would say the fact that OpenAI has a reasoning model now that is comparable so quickly makes me think that like either they worked around the clock or they were coming to the same idea, right?
还没有向公众发布。有人猜测 OpenAI 已经在做类似的事情，但他们还没有发表。所以 DeepSeek 算是抢先了一步。甚至还有更多，更具推测性的是，有人从 OpenAI 偷了这个想法并给了 DeepSeek。这纯属猜测。但我会说，OpenAI 现在有一个推理模型，能够如此迅速地达到相当的水平，这让我认为，要么他们没日没夜地工作，要么他们得出了同样的想法，对吧？
And it's probably the latter. Probably DeepSeek saw where the wind was blowing. And, um, and they both kind of came to that answer around the same time. That would be my guess. It makes sense. So there's lots of cases like that, right? I don't know. Online, I saw someone using the term nerd snipe. Wait, what does that mean?
这很可能是后者。DeepSeek 可能看到了风向。而且，他们俩几乎在同一时间得出了那个答案。这是我的猜测。这说得通。所以有很多这样的情况，对吧？我不知道。在网上，我看到有人用“书呆子狙击”（nerd snipe）这个词。等等，那是什么意思？
Same kind of idea. Like people, or I think since you're a YouTuber, you're like working on some like new cool project, you know, you think is like crazy and innovative and someone else just releases a video of the same thing because you didn't get out fast enough, or like you said, there are, I mean, what, half dozen, dozen, I know, probably like a half dozen super serious competitors and like a said, there are, I mean, what half dozen, dozen, I probably like a half dozen super serious competitors and like a dozen like within striking range of doing these kind of similar. I don't, I don't want to demean them by saying those like chat, but like question
同样的想法。就像人们，或者我想因为你是个 YouTuber，你正在做一个新的很酷的项目，你知道，你认为这很疯狂且具有创新性，而其他人只是发布了一个同样东西的视频，因为你没有足够快地拿出来，或者像你说的，有，我的意思是，什么，半打，一打，我知道，可能有半打超级认真的竞争对手，像我说的，有，我的意思是，什么半打，一打，我可能有半打超级认真的竞争对手，像
and answer AI agents, um, agentic stuff, the, the reasoning, like all of these. And so. Like you said, you're, you're hard at work trying to refine a project. You're not sure if it's a big enough innovation, whatever, and then someone else just goes ahead and releases it. Yeah, and so you get sort of sniped out of it, right?
一打在做这些类似事情的射程之内。我不想通过说那些像聊天，但像问题和回答 AI 代理，代理式的东西，推理，所有这些来贬低他们。所以。就像你说的，你正在努力完善一个项目。你不确定它是否是一个足够大的创新，无论如何，然后其他人就直接发布了它。是的，所以你被某种程度上狙击了，对吧？
Like someone got it before you, just before you were gonna do it. Yeah, yeah, totally. I mean, I think one of the trends was that like math, answering math questions was becoming like a big benchmark that was very important. And so I think that led a lot of people to the same conclusion.
就像有人在你之前得到了它，就在你打算做之前。是的，是的，完全正确。我的意思是，我认为趋势之一是，像数学，回答数学问题正在成为一个非常重要的基准。所以我认为这导致很多人得出了同样的结论。
Like if the metric had been like right the best play or something, then we might've ended up with a totally different system. But I think once people got excited about solving these like high school math problems, I think then, then that kind of set the course for, for all these companies. The answering math stuff was really bad for a long time.
如果指标是像“写出最好的剧本”之类的，那么我们可能最终会得到一个完全不同的系统。但我认为一旦人们对解决这些高中数学问题感到兴奋，我认为那时，这就为所有这些公司设定了方向。回答数学问题在很长一段时间里真的很糟糕。
So yeah, it's kind of thing. And I, I feel, and maybe I'm kind of wrong. I feel the store like coding maybe is, is a, one of those things that when you think through like lead code style problems, like there are definite like set up where you're given a very high level question. And then, and there are benchmarks already have these in there,
所以是的，这是那种事情。而且我，我感觉，也许我有点错了。我觉得像编码可能是一个，当你思考像 LeetCode 风格的问题时，是那种事情之一，有明确的设置，你被给出一个非常高级的问题。然后，而且基准测试已经有了这些，
but I still feel like performance isn't amazing once you get off the bench, like that they've not seen before, right? So when you give these sort of high level problems and you kind of have a very specific known output for the program and it should be compilable and it should be, it's harder, yeah, of course than the math problem,
但我仍然觉得一旦你离开基准测试，性能就不那么惊人了，他们以前没见过，对吧？所以当你给出这些高级问题，并且你对程序有一个非常具体的已知输出，它应该是可编译的，它应该是，它更难，是的，当然比数学问题更难，
but it seems within striking distance. Yeah, I mean, you know, traditionally in machine learning, we have this concept called leaking the label, which means like, you know, if you took, okay, if you took the examples you trained on for the stop sign trainer and you just fed them back in and you get them all right, that doesn't mean you have a perfect system because you're kind of cheating, right?
但它似乎在射程之内。是的，我的意思是，你知道，在机器学习中，我们有一个概念叫“泄露标签”，这意味着，你知道，如果你拿了，好的，如果你拿了你为停车标志训练器训练的例子，然后你只是把它们喂回去，你把它们都做对了，这并不意味着你有一个完美的系统，因为你在某种程度上作弊了，对吧？
Like you might, you might have just memorized all those examples and you can't know anything else it's possible. Right. Yep. Um, but the problem is how do you not leak the label when you're and you can't know anything else, it's possible, right? Yep. But the problem is how do you not leak the label when you're trading on the entire internet? And so I think what they've found is a lot of these cases
就像你可能，你可能只是记住了所有那些例子，而你不知道其他任何事情，这是可能的。对。是的。嗯，但问题是当你，你不知道其他任何事情，这是可能的，对吧？对。是的。但问题是当你用整个互联网进行训练时，你怎么能不泄露标签？所以我认为他们发现了很多这些情况，
where like the AI solves math problems or the AI solves leak code problems is they've leaked the label and the AI is literally outputting an answer that somebody else, some other human wrote to that lead code problem. And so they've done experiments where they've released things that they know are not on the internet and the AI's have struggled mightily with it.
比如 AI 解决数学问题或 AI 解决 LeetCode 问题，他们泄露了标签，AI 实际上是在输出别人，某个其他人写的那个 LeetCode 问题的答案。所以他们做过实验，他们发布了他们知道不在互联网上的东西，而 AI 在这方面非常吃力。
I feel like until we get proper calculator use and tool use more broadly, I think it's gonna be very hard for AI to solve these problems. Well, this has been a great topic and very timely. I know you've been working on reinforcement learning for a long time, but I feel it has, like you said, it's kind of reached a certain hubbub in the everyday discussions recently. So I'm happy to have a sort of great overview of what it is and what it's about.
我觉得在我们更广泛地使用计算器和工具之前，我认为 AI 很难解决这些问题。嗯，这是一个很好的话题，而且非常及时。我知道你长期以来一直致力于强化学习，但我感觉它，就像你说的，最近在日常讨论中达到了一定的热度。所以我很高兴能对它是什么以及它是关于什么的有一个很好的概述。
Yeah, totally. If folks have any questions, they can just reach out on our Discord or email or in my case, social media. We need a reinforcement learning algorithm to get Patrick on X. That needs to be the next thing. Okay. Well. But yeah. So I did look it up. So Dolly one was four years ago. You were right. That was very good.
是的，完全正确。如果大家有任何问题，他们可以直接在我们的 Discord 或电子邮件上联系，或者在我的情况下，社交媒体。我们需要一个强化学习算法来让 Patrick 上 X。那需要成为下一件事。好的。好吧。但是是的。所以我确实查了一下。所以 DALL-E 1 是四年前。你是对的。那非常好。
And then Dolly two is what I was first trying. And that was three years ago. Nice. So you're actually you're very accurate despite it just being off the top of your head. Well, I remember, you know, 20 these things where like you connect it to stories. Like I remember there's this woman, she's very influential in AI. Her name is Fei-Fei Lee. And I remember being in this dinner and her and her student were there. And she said something like, and this was again, a long time ago, but she said something like, oh it was, oh we were writing captions from images. So basically given an image write a caption so that we could for accessibility reasons. And Facebook I think still has that in the product today. It's like if you're blind or something you can click on an
然后 DALL-E 2 是我第一次尝试的。那是三年前。不错。所以你实际上，你非常准确，尽管这只是你脱口而出的。嗯，我记得，你知道，20 这些事情，就像你把它和故事联系起来一样。就像我记得有一位女士，她在 AI 领域非常有影响力。她的名字是李飞飞。我记得在一次晚餐上，她和她的学生在那里。她说了一些话，比如，这又是很久以前的事了，但她说了一些话，比如，哦，是，哦，我们正在为图像编写标题。所以基本上给定一个图像，写一个标题，这样我们就可以出于可访问性的原因。我想 Facebook 今天在产品中仍然有这个。就像如果你是盲人或类似的人，你可以点击一个
image and it'll say what is going on in the image. I remember her saying, that's cool, but it'd be really cool if you could go from the description and create the image. And that always stuck with me. I mean, I was like a decade ago. That always stuck with me. And then I remember when Dolly came out, I was like, wow, it's like the, something that I thought was like a joke,
图像，它会说图像中发生了什么。我记得她说，那很酷，但如果你能从描述中创建图像，那会真的很酷。那一直印在我的脑海里。我的意思是，那大概是十年前的事了。那一直印在我的脑海里。然后我记得当 DALL-E 出来时，我想，哇，这就像，我以为是笑话的东西，
but then it really happened. Like is, for me it was like an amazing experience. That's why I remember it. I think people have started to get a little fatigued on the AI thing. And it's hard to know, is it, you always hit plateaus. Is it like plateauing in terms of like actual functionality? Is it on-run and exponential?
但后来它真的发生了。就像，对我来说，这是一种惊人的体验。这就是为什么我记得它。我认为人们已经开始对 AI 的事情感到有点疲劳了。而且很难知道，是吗，你总是会遇到平台期。它是在实际功能方面达到平台期了吗？它是指数级的吗？
And exponentials always look self-similar no matter where you look, right? And you just sort of like, we can't feel the growth. And then you tell stories like you're saying, or even about Dolly being, you know, four years ago only, and like talk about the, the repaint or the flux now versus Dolly, you know, just three or four years ago. It's not that long and there are lots better.
指数总是看起来自相似的，无论你在哪里看，对吧？你只是觉得，我们感觉不到增长。然后你讲故事，就像你说的，或者甚至关于 DALL-E 是，你知道，只有四年前，就像谈论现在的重绘或 Flux 与 DALL-E，你知道，仅仅三四年前。时间并不长，而且有很多更好的。
Yeah, I mean, yeah, actually that's a good point. I'll end with, with my, where I think this is going. I think that despite loving, reinforcing learning and everything, I don't think that AI should be making a lot of decisions in isolation. I think that it should be working together with people. And so, you know, the recraft is a great example
是的，我的意思是，是的，实际上这是一个很好的观点。我将以，以我认为这要去向哪里结束。我认为尽管热爱强化学习和一切，我不认为 AI 应该孤立地做出很多决定。我认为它应该与人一起工作。所以，你知道，Recraft 是一个很好的例子，
where it's not just an API you call and get an image, but it's like an experience and like you iterate and you say, Hey, I want this to be all different or Hey, I want this. I want an axe in this person's hand or a phone or whatever. Right. And so I think it's going to be really about collaboration and reinforcement learning is always going to be really important, but it's going be really about collaboration. And reinforcement learning is always gonna be really important, but it's gonna be important in the way that the actions are more like suggesting things to people. So in other words, reinforcement learning
它不仅仅是你调用并获取图像的 API，它更像是一种体验，你迭代，你说，嘿，我想要这个完全不同，或者嘿，我想要这个。我想要这个人的手里有一把斧头，或者一部手机，或者其他什么。对。所以我认为这真的将是关于协作，强化学习总是会非常重要，但它将是关于协作。强化学习总是会非常重要，但它将以操作更像是向人们建议事情的方式变得重要。所以换句话说，强化学习
to like book a flight for you, probably not a good idea. Cause if one out of a hundred times you go to Tokyo by accident, right, you're gonna be pretty upset. I might be happy, that sounds great. Yeah, actually Tokyo is amazing. Yeah, actually I don't wanna say anywhere we don't wanna go, cause we have a list that are almost like, anyway.
来为你预订航班，可能不是个好主意。因为如果一百次里有一次你意外去了东京，对吧，你会非常心烦。我可能会很高兴，那听起来很棒。是的，实际上东京很棒。是的，实际上我不想说任何我们不想去的地方，因为我们有一个几乎是，无论如何。
So Antarctica. Okay, sounds horrible. But you still need reinforcement learning to like suggest, like, you know, come up with like three different hypotheticals send it to the person should you text them or email them etc like there's still a lot of decisions to be made but I don't believe tons of people are gonna lose their jobs entirely I think that work is gonna change just like it did with with the invention of the motor and stuff. So. Well, you heard it here first.
所以南极洲。好的，听起来很可怕。但你仍然需要强化学习来建议，比如，你知道，想出三个不同的假设，发送给那个人，你应该给他们发短信还是发电子邮件等等，仍然有很多决定要做，但我不相信很多人会完全失去工作，我认为工作会改变，就像电动机的发明等等一样。所以。好吧，你在这里先听到了。
The JSON future AI is not too scary coin. Yeah. Yeah. Don't be worried about it. Just be adaptable. If you're adaptable, I think you'll be just fine. And, and, oh, and coding will probably be one of the last jobs to be eliminated by the way. So if you're worried about So if you're worried about,
JSON 未来的 AI 并不是太可怕的硬币。是的。是的。不要担心它。只要适应就行。如果你适应力强，我想你会没事的。而且，哦，编码可能是最后被淘汰的工作之一，顺便说一句。所以如果你担心，所以如果你担心，
if you're worried about, yeah, please stay in coding. Not just because we want you to keep listening to the podcast, but tell all your friends to get into coding, stay in coding. If they're worried about their job being eliminated, they should be a coder. That's like one of the last jobs that's gonna go. I mean, trust me on this.
如果你担心，是的，请留在编码领域。不仅仅是因为我们希望你继续收听播客，而是告诉所有的朋友去学习编码，留在编码领域。如果他们担心自己的工作被淘汰，他们应该成为一名程序员。那是最后会消失的工作之一。我的意思是，相信我。
Like we are going to lose so many doctors. We should probably lose all the CEOs before we lose the coders. Oh, no, no, no. All right. All right. We got to wrap. We got to wrap, guys. We got to wrap. They're phoning me from the other room and telling us we're out of time. That's right. Hey, I didn't say anything about HR. What's that? Oh, yeah, we're wrapping up. All right. This was so fun. Thanks everyone for tuning in and thanks Patrick for bearing with me and my rants on
就像我们将失去很多医生。我们可能应该在失去程序员之前失去所有的首席执行官。哦，不，不，不。好吧。好吧，我们得结束了。我们得结束了，伙计们。我们得结束了。他们从隔壁房间给我打电话，告诉我们时间到了。没错。嘿，我没说关于人力资源的事。那是什么？哦，是的，我们要结束了。好吧。这太有趣了。感谢大家的收听，也感谢 Patrick 忍受我和我的关于
reinforcement learning. This is great. Very illuminating. This is awesome. I learned a lot today. So. Cool. All right, everyone.
强化学习的咆哮。这太棒了。非常有启发性。这太棒了。我今天学到了很多。所以。酷。好吧，大家。
We'll catch you later. Eric Barndaler. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们回头见。Eric Barndaler。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。